[Musique]
professeur nokia ou bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons encore pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinker view est
ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement donc je m'appelle renaud
piarroux j'ai 60 ans je suis professeur
à sorbonne universités chef de service à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
je suis pédiatre de formation spécialisé
dans les maladies infectieuses et
tropicales mais aussi j'ai une thèse en
biologie et donc j'ai cette double
valence cliniques et biologiques et je
m'occupe beaucoup d'épidémie et ça
maintenant depuis plus de 25 ans
donc on a décidé de vous faire revenir
pour faire un point sur la
désinformation en temps d'épidémie faire
une analyse carré source et carys cupic
sur ce qui s'est passé en 2010 avec le
choléra comment l'om est comment les
différents institutionnels ont
communiqué autour de ça qu'est ce qui
s'est passé on fera ensuite un point sur
ce qui nous intéresse aussi le co vide
et la stratégie vaccinale qu'est ce qui
se passe avec les variants qu'est ce qui
se passe avec tout ça et tout ce blu
biguglia on va essayer d'y voir un peu
plus clair mais là on va on va prendre
notre temps pour parler de ce qui s'est
passé en 2010 sur une épidémie de
choléra
importés par des népalais et c'est à
vous merci donc effectivement je
trouvais que c'était aussi une bonne
idée que de
de reprendre ce qu'on avait un tout
petit peu abordé l'autre fois et deux
de partir sur cette épidémie qui a
commencé en 2010 c'est fini en 2019 qui
nous apporte plein d'informations sur la
manière dont on communique en période
d'épidémie donc je vais commencer par
très brièvement expliqué comment le
choléra a été introduit en haïti sts
haïti en fait un pays dans l'est dans la
caraïbe qui
n'avait en fait jamais eu de choléra
pendant un moment on a dit après le
choléra depuis
1960 mais qu'en fait même avant il y en
a pas eu on n'a retrouvé aucune trace de
choléra parce que le pays était à
l'écart finalement de du commerce
international et et s'est retrouvée ne
pas avoir de choléra pourtant en en 2010
une épidémie de choléra extrêmement
violente a commencé en haïti en fait le
point de départ de cette épidémie se
situer au népal on est en septembre 2010
il y à du choléra au népal en ce moment
là à ce moment là il ya une épidémie qui
qui sévit au départ au népal et elle
touche à la fin du mois de septembre
elle touche la capitale katmandou c'est
à ce moment là que en
haïti enfin on prépare la relève des
soldats de la minustah alors la minustah
c'est là la mission des nations unies
pour la stabilité d'haïti c'est une
mission de maintien de la paix dans un
pays qui est pas franchement en guerre
mais qui une instabilité politique qui a
été mise en place en 2004
ensuite dans l'est les années qui
suivent bon la minustah est sur place au
début de l'année 2010 il ya un
tremblement de terre très important en
janvier 2010 en haïti et
ça n'a pas un rapport direct mais bon le
la minustah est prolongée elle est là et
il faut faire la relève des soldats on
est au népal des soldats un peu plus
d'un millier de soldats vont partir pour
haïti
ils sont examinés pour pour une
opération extérieure c'est à dire une
examens cliniques etc puis ensuite ils
sont lâchés en permission chez eux
pendant une dizaine de jours et ils
reviennent pour embarquer et partir pour
haïti au mois d'octobre et tout ça le 8
octobre à peu près donc tout ça se fait
pendant cette période où il ya une
épidémie de choléra ils ne sont ni
vacciné ni traite le traitement
particulier ni examiné aînés ou de
recherche microbiologiques pour le
choléra il on marque dans l'avion et
park pour haïti
donc le 8 octobre la relève arrive en
haïti est qu'ils vont s'installer dans
un dans différents camps le principal le
plus important se trouve au centre du
pays dans une proximité d'une ville qui
s'appelle mire ballet est donc ce camp
est entourée d'une petite rivière et le
on va on va s'apercevoir assez vite qui
est un problème d'assainissement au
niveau du temps alors le problème là il
ya un plan de la région on voit bien le
le corps qui est indiquée en rouge sur
le sur le schéma il est donc un peu au
sud de la ville de mirebalais et tout
autour bayadh et des influences qui vont
aller vers mire ballet et ensuite
entraîné
arrivée sur le fleuve artibonite que le
principal fleuve d'haïti et c'est juste
en face de ce camp dans un petit village
d'une vingtaine de maisons qu'on va voir
apparaître les premiers cas de choléra
le problème de de l'assainissement du
camp est assez évident quand on regarde
cette photographie qui montent
finalement une fosse à ciel ouvert dans
lequel
le la compagnie haïtienne qui est chargé
d'évacuer les les fosses septiques du
camp des verts sz le contenu des fosses
septiques les légendes du village
explique que quand il pleut ça déborde
et on voit d'ailleurs la trace des
ruisseaux qui partent de cette fosse
sceptique je suis allé sur place sur les
vues et c'est pas du tout fermé mes
enfants peuvent se balader dans le coin
les animaux des divas dedans dans le
coin donc il ya absolument aucune
protection qui est prise
le deuxième gros problème de
autour de ce camp c'est le lorsque la
fosse à ciel ouvert est vraiment pleine
il arrive et on pense que c'est ce qui
s'est passé vers la mi-octobre que le le
contractant haïtien le choc les
chauffeurs des charges en fait le
contenu dans le dans la nature ce qui
était déjà dans la nature la fosse
ouverte mais par exemple dans un cours
d'eau hélas cette photo a été prise par
un photographe de la socialité de presse
qui
donc woippy le montre bien comment les
choses se font
à partir de cet endroit là les
finalement les excrétas les matières
fécales vont descendre arriver jusqu'à
la ville de mirebalais
et ensuite prendre le que le fleuve
artibonite pendant les premiers les
premières dizaines de kilomètres qui est
assez peu de personne à part amir valle
mais en dehors de la hiace peu de
personnes qui prennent de l'eau au
fleuve parce qu'ils prennent de l'eau
sur les affluents mais quand on arrive
près de la côte on arrive dans une zone
de plaine c'est une zone de plaine
rizicole et l'aller les gens vont
travailler dans les rizières pendant
toute la journée les rizières sont
alimentés par des canaux qui partent de
l'artibonite et lorsqu'ils ont soif les
gens doivent owni directement au niveau
des canaux et de là on a des milliers
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui sont exposées finalement aux eaux
usées du camp militaire qui est à des
dizaines de kilomètres plus en amont
alors pour résumer trivialement c'est un
peu comme en montagne quand il ya les
moutons qui font pipi dans la rivière en
altitude faut éviter de boire l'eau
parce que ça descend sa descendance sauf
que là c'est pas des moutons si les
casques bleus est en fait beau regard
vrai problème de ce côté là mais les
gens qui sont dans les rizières n'ont
pas de tellement de solution c'est de
venir avec un bidon d'eau tout cas ils
ne font pas et c'est comme ça que ça se
passe oui
donc là on a une une image qui a été
prise enfin une figure qui a été
construite au moment de l'explosion du
choléra alors dans le bas artibonite
on est le 22 octobre ça fait quelques
jours que les que les soldats sont
arrivés et là tout d'un coup dans le bas
artibonite
on s'aperçoit mais du jour au lendemain
on a tout d'un coup 500 puis mille
nouveaux cas de plus c'est très très
vite en l'espace de 24 48 heures des
milliers de cas qui affluent vers les
structures de coûts de de soins de
l'artibonite qui vont se faire soigner
pour des diarrhées terrible avec des
vomissements et des déshydratations et
déjà on a à peine à 48 heures du début
qu'on est déjà 138 morts dont quelque
chose d' extrêmement sévère qui survient
dans ce bas artibonite
jeu les villages et fait une série de
cartes qui vont montrer le l'expansion
de l'épidémie c'est les cartes
d'incidence et le nombre de cas sur le
nombre d'habitants dans toutes les
communes d'haïti et là c'est le mois
d'octobre qui on va le voir les mois
suivants donc au mois d'octobre on voit
que le en orange vous avez la commune de
mireval et où il ya une une épidémie
très sévère qui a qui a frappé et puis
vers le bas de l'artibonite vous avez
aussi un certain nombre d'autres
communes qui sont touchés et puis au fil
des mois on va avoir cette espèce
d'expansion comme une onde de choc qui
va vraiment frappé la totalité du
territoire haïtien d'une manière
extrêmement sévère là on arrive au mois
de mars on ça semble se calmer mais en
fête se prépare une nouvelle vague qui
va être provoqué par l'arrivée de la
saison des pluies
alors pour ceux plus simplement une
petite question sur le nombre de morts
pour qu'on comprenne la gravité de la
situation haïti c'est un pays qui à
l'époque fait entre 10 et 11 millions
d'habitants maintenance et 12 millions
d'habitants et il y a un certain nombre
d'études qui sont faites qui sont faites
par en particulier par m sans frontières
et puis centre qui est un organisme qui
fait des études épidémiologiques souvent
pour msf et donc il ya deux publications
je vais pas les détails et mais
simplement prendre dans ses publications
donc c'est des des enquêtes qui sont
faites au porte à porte dans des zones
urbaines ou dans des zones rurales où la
leon demande aux famille s'il ya eu des
problèmes dans les mois qui ont précédé
ces faits au printemps 2011 donc c'est
pour explorer la la période entre
novembre et mars novembre 2010 mars 2011
et c'est de repérer si dans la famille
il ya eu des cas de diarrhée sévère ou
des décès et là on s'aperçoit que par
exemple sur une enquête qui enquête
auprès d'un peu moins de 71 1000
personnes on retrouve déjà pratiquement
un millier de décès dont 772 lors d'un
épisode de diarrhée ça fait en gros 1,1
pour cent de la population qui meurt
d'une gare et juste au moment de
l'épidémie de choléra donc le la très
grande parce qu'on ne peut pas faire des
tests il n'y a pas eu des tests faits
mais là une très grande probabilité pour
que ces gens là soient vraiment mort du
choléra et l'étude est reproduite avec
des méthodes un tout petit peu
différente mais dans d'autres zones et
on retrouve sur une sur un nombre de
pertes de cas plus grands exactement la
même chose avec un taux de mortalité par
maladies diarrhéiques dans cette période
là un peu au-dessus de 1% alors quand on
pense qu haïti ses 10 millions
d'habitants alors tout le territoire
peut-être pas été touchés de la même
manière dont on peut facilement imaginer
que plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont mortes à ce moment là là
dessus quelques milliers seulement ont
été vus dans les structures de soins et
sont comptabilisés
au final des années après il ya eu
encore d'autres vagues d'autres décès on
en est quand même à huit cent vingt
mille cas déclarés dans quelque chose
d'assez énorme et près de 10 de 10000
morts recensés en réalité donc ce que le
disait probablement des dizaines de
milliers d'autres qui sont non recensés
et c'est la pire épidémie de choléra de
ces vingt dernières années sur
l'ensemble de la planète en 2010 2011
2012 il ya autant de cas de choléra en
haïti que dans toute l'afrique
intertropicale donc quelque chose de
vraiment
très très important parce que l'afrique
intertropicale c'est un milliard
d'habitants haïti c'est 10 millions
voilà le l'histoire elle est assez clair
maintenant il est important de dire
pourquoi on affirme maintenant que
l'origine du choléra c'est bien
l'arrivée de ces casques bleus népalais
donc je vais juste parler de trois
études trois études qui ont été faites
donc des études scientifiques ont été
publiés qui ont été soumises à contre
expertises et des fois difficile
évidemment parce que le sujet est
brûlant la première donc c'est une étude
épidémiologique j ai participé les mêmes
mise mise en oeuvre j'ai coordonné et
elle montre donner des arguments très
solides un point de vue épidémiologique
j'ai déjà expliqué la corrélation
spatiale et temporelle entre l'arrivée
de ces soldats et le début de l'épidémie
cette vingtaine de maisons ce petit
village aucune raison de devoir arriver
une maladie exotique qui ne qui
n'existait pas en haïti c'est pas des
gens qui voyagent c'est une zone rurale
avec peu de contacts avec l'extérieur
donc c'est un argument solide deuxième
argument c'est la chronologie avec le
début au tour donc de la ville de
mirebalais avec une une vraie épidémie
déjà avec plusieurs centaines de cas par
jour puis quelques jours après une
épidémie d'ampleur encore plus grande
mais en suivant le cours de l'artibonite
et puis dans les dans les semaines qui
suivent ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
sous la forme de cette onde de choc et
donc ça c'est un argument aussi pour
expliquer la
fonctionnement d'épidémie une chose très
intéressante dans les courbes épidémique
celle du milieu et celle de l'artibonite
de du bas artibonite
on voit que dans l'est alors qu'il y
avait déjà des cas mire ballet mais
pendant quelques jours et absolument
rien l'eau n'est pas encore arrivé en
quelque sorte et tout d'un coup alors
qu'on parle de 0k on a donc le premier
jour un millier de cas le deuxième jour
2000 cas troisième lyon 2004 près de dix
mille cas en quelques jours qui arrivent
c'est c'est pas suffisant pour que les
gens se contaminent entre eux ça veut
dire c'est pas une épidémie ça ça veut
dire que c'est autant de personnes qui
se sont contaminées
simultanément à la même source certains
sont tombés malades en quelques heures
d'autres en un jour 2 jours 3 jours
c'est comme ça que ça se passe avec le
choléra et ça on a vraiment dans ce cas
là faut qu'on trouve une source unique
est la seule source unique c'est
évidemment le système des canaux de
l'artibonite et le fait que les gens
buvaient cette hausse il ya une crise
une corrélation spatial tout à fait
complète je reviens juste parce que
quand on voit par exemple sur la courbe
du bas pour le reste d'haïti passe
quelque chose que maintenant on a tous
l'habitude de voir c'est cette espèce de
courbe exponentielle où ça monte tout
doucement tout doucement pendant un
certain temps pour vraiment exploser au
bout d'un certain temps c'est pas du
tout celle qu'on a dans l'artibonite
le deuxième type de preuves qui est très
important aussi c'est en fait ce qu'on
va appeler la preuve adn comme
finalement la police scientifique peut
essayer de confondre un coupable en
retrouvant son adn sur la scène du crime
là on a un scientifique qui a eu l'idée
tout à fait
géniale de contacter les collègues
népalais en leur disant envoyez nous vos
souche
et on va les lire leur génome total on
va les étudier à fond et ça va montrer
on saura si c'est ça ou c'est pas ça
comme les népalais étaient sûrs que ce
n'était pas à eux ils l'ont fait
volontiers manque de bol quand on voit
le résultat de ceux de cette étude y
avait donc finalement une petite
diversité au niveau du népal il y avait
trois groupes de quatre groupes de
souche est l'un des quatre groupes de
souche collait parfaitement à eau sous
ce qu'on avait trouvé en haïti c'est au
milieu de ce de ce schéma donc là une
preuve vraiment très très forte parce
qu'on a trouvé nulle part ailleurs des
souches aussi ressemblante la
ressemblance était totale
et là à la fin c'est finalement dernier
parti que je vais que je vais citer sur
cette histoire là à la fin c'est devenu
un cas d'école c'est vraiment maintenant
il a des auteurs ont écrit des articles
pour expliquer que c'est vraiment le un
exemple l'exemple typique comment la
science peut résoudre une controverse
parce qu'évidemment il ya une
controverse sur l'origine du choléra en
haïti et donc c'est sorti dans un
article et ça reprend la gelée si vous
voulez le regarder de près vous avez
toute la séquence de ce qui s'est passé
mais à chaque fois de toute façon vous
pouvez aller sur l'article parce que
j'ai mis les références complètes vous
coupent pourquoi une controverse il y
avait une controverse on va la voir
parce que évidemment l'onu n'a pas admis
tout de suite que je pouvais avoir une
responsabilité dans cette épidémie et on
va le on va le voir bien ambiant de
détail et
donc dire que ça pouvait être les
népalaise a d'abord été présentée comme
une rumeur est comme une rumeur infondée
qui a présenté sa commune rumeurs
infondées les officiels on va on va le
voir plus plus précisément
les experts
et donc donc tout ce qui est paroles un
peu institutionnel c'est
oui c'est ligués pour dire non non ça
n'est ce n'est absolument pas quelque
chose
de crédible cette histoire de deux n'est
pas laisser des histoires politiques
c'est une opération dix qui disent c'est
sain ils n'ont pas dit
conspirationnistes ils ont parlé de par
exemple le maire de mire ballet
évidemment lui pouvait pas dire
autrement parce qu'il a bien vu que
l'épidémie avait commencé chez lui il a
été accusé de dire ça pas des fins
politiques voilà je vous souhaite
continuer ben on va justement sur ça et
donc maintenant on va parler on en
connaît l'histoire
on va voir comment se fait la
désinformation avec des étapes
successives mais en fait un briquet
comme l'effacement des preuves les
éléments de langage on va en parler et
puis même quelque chose d'assez original
qui est la manipulation des cartes alors
premier point juste pour donner un peu
les éléments de langage
simplement là pour
d'abord dire que évidemment c'est un
exemple parmi un autre et ça n'est ce
n'est pas remis à remettre en question
le journal encaissés dans cette histoire
là il n'a fait que rapporter ce que
disaient les les personnes interrogées
donc effectivement il n'y a pas de
problème d'assainissement c'est une
rumeur s'est on a des belles fosses
septiques n'y a pas de problème vous
avez vu ce que c'était mais ça n'empêche
pas d'affirmer le contraire et puis ce
qu'on a ce cette intervention de du dr
chaignat qui est qui s'occupe du choléra
à l'om est ce qu est la coordinatrice de
choléra le msc qui explique que
ça peut pas être les humanitaires alors
militaire humanitaire est ce que c'est
tout à fait la même chose ça peut pas
être les humanitaires c'est absolument
impossible dans d'autres articles l
expliquera que le temps que les ans
arrivée tout ça le choléra enfin la
trouver des raisons pour dire c'est pas
possible et donc ça c'est ce qui est dit
ce sont les éléments de langage c'est ce
qu'on va retrouver on ne verra pas de
gens témoigner si ce n'est des personnes
relativement
peu crédible comme un paysan ou quelque
chose comme ça la deuxième chose qu'on
peut aller voir c'est là c'est un petit
film qu'est sur youtube des journalistes
évidemment quand même se sont posés la
question minimum trois journalistes à
qui un journaliste haïtien
roberson alphonse qui va regarder qui on
peut retrouver aussi son témoignage il y
à un américain s'appelle jonathan katz
qui fanatiques le écrit mais ce que je
présente là ce que je montre c'est un
autre américain sebastian walker qui
travaille pour al jazeera ils arrivent
au camp militaire le 27 octobre au
moment où les militaires sont en train
de déterrer les tuyaux qui relié leur
banque leur bloc sanitaire à la rivière
ces tuyaux étaient
les habitants du village on avait parlé
aussi devenu un peu plus tard donc avait
été mis par les militaires quand le les
fosses septiques était trop plein il les
vidanges et comme ça avant que le camion
ne vienne
quelque chose d'important c'est que
j'ai fait mon investigation juré c'est
assez longtemps et simplement la fin
j'ai compris qu'il y avait eu une autre
investigation pendant les semaines qui
avaient précédé mais je n'ai eu le
rapport qu'à la fin qui m'a été remis
par le directeur de la lutte contre 2 le
laboratoire d'épidémiologie de la
recherche et c'est certainement cette
personne n'avait pas pu le faire sans
que ce soit un ordre donné par le
président d'haïti à l'époque le
président rené préval et donc je
découvre ce rapport et je découvre à la
fin que il ya eu une enquête qui a été
menée avant même que le choléra ne nous
on explose dans le bas artibonite
il y avait déjà une équipe qui était
venue à mireval et parce que amir ben
aleya un hôpital tenu par des médecins
cubains soutenus par des médecins
cubains mais aussi des médecins haïtiens
et les cubains quand ils ont vu arriver
les premiers cas de diarrhée la sévérité
ils ont tout de suite signalé le
problème est tout de suite sar
enclencher une mission sur le terrain
vie pour celui le professionnalisme des
médecins cubains qui sont très
opérationnels en général oui c'est le
soft power de cuba en tout cas ils sont
ils étaient très nombreux en haïti à ce
moment là il ya eu une aide très
importante qui a été apportée alors on
va trouver ce rapport est vraiment très
détaillé ce qui a été fait jour après
jour et on s'aperçoit que le 21 donc
c'est au moment où ça explose dans le
bar team unique mais ils ne savent pas
ils sont les enquêteurs les uns
d'épidémiologique sont autour du camp et
vont justement c'est de voir ce qui se
passe autour de ces tuyaux le 21 le 22
et donc le lacet tuyaux sont nommés et
ils vont voir aussi ce qui se passe
autour de cette fosse à ciel ouvert et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
rapport est resté tenue mis de côté
pendant un peu plus d'un mois avant que
je puisse la voir et personne ne l'avait
vu et puis finalement même l'onu même
une mission envoyée par l'onu
reconnaîtra et qu'il
qu'il y avait effectivement qu'il ya eu
des travaux au niveau de ce bloc
sanitaire tout juste après le début de
l'épidémie sans expliquer pourquoi ces
travaux avaient eu lieu c'est ce que je
sebastian walker avec vu ces questions
internes et de khimki la souce derrière
des beavers encore c'est le délai rivers
et livre écrit par un professeur
américain de ucla de
l'université de californie los angeles
s'appellera le frére x professeur de
santé publique qui au moment où
l'épidémie à démarré il a
il tenait déjà un
site internet sur le sur le choléra et
sur un épidémiologiste connu qui
s'appelle john snow c'est pas celui de
game of thrones est donc il a été tout
de suite très intéressés et ses îles et
très vite il a eu la puce à l'oreille à
propos de delà
du langage et des éléments de langage il
a trouvé que c'était bizarre en
particulier que on verra on explique
qu'il fallait pas rechercher l'origine
de l'épidémie et ça évidemment il s'est
dit actions ce qui va pas il a commencé
à recueillir des documents écrire assez
naïvement aux uns aux autres
il m'a écrit un moment et puis on a
commencé à échanger et c'est comme ça
que aînés des rumeurs
je continue donc on a là quelques
éléments qui montrent l'est on y milieu
d'un rapport de l'onu mais il ya un
problème dans ce cas là bien sûr encore
cacher les rapport épidémiologique on
peut enlever les tuyaux on peut dire aux
militaires font ça n'y a pas besoin de
leur dire de se taire c'est la grande
muette mais le microbe peut passer à
table il peut parler lui aussi est
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a vu plus tard
alors que faire dans ce cas là et ça
c'est c'est intéressant
c'est plus tard que j'ai vu ça c'est joe
nathan katz donc ce journaliste dont un
des journalistes je vous ai parlé qui
al'idée je pense qu'il a dû être
informés quand même il a eu l'idée
d'utiliser une loi américaine qui permet
d'avoir communication des échanges
des messages échangés au sein des
administrations
je me souviens plus comment s'appelle ce
truc là c'est un peu loin peau pour le
lire c'est le
c'est un acte
c'est le une formation à cris d'hommes
information act qui permet d'avoir ça
donc il doit être régi ses voisins non
fissa je sais pas frémi fin juin c'est
ça oui freedom et voilà et donc et il
s'aperçoit en fait qu'il ya des
communications entre les personnes du
cdc que dans ses communications il parle
du national security council et ils
disent que alors le national security
council ces espèces de conseil de
défense en quelque sorte il est
directement sous la sous la coupe du
président et se national security
council président américain s'était
barack obama à l'époque était très
préoccupé de ce qui se passait et en
fait l'idée c'était que le cdc venait
d'avoir des souches et qu' il pouvait
arriver au fil des analyses à dire tiens
cette souche vient peut-être du népal ou
en tout cas de l'asie du sud et il
fallait préparer les éléments de langage
pour que c'est ce qu'expliquait dans ces
mails pour que le ne viennent pas à dire
de manière un peu pernicieuse c'est que
le mot est là dans ces mails que
finalement c'est peut-être le népal et
qu'ils ont apportées donc on voit très
bien que cette les épidémiologistes
américains étaient sous pression de
l'administration américaine d'ailleurs
le cdc c'est quand on va sur une adresse
ses 17 cdc.com annoncé on sait que ils
dépendent du gouvernement environ 15 et
une question internet de f zero 7
quelles seraient les arguments ne pas
rechercher l'origine du d'épidémie ou
alors les arguments c'est
qu'ils ont été dit c'est que on a trop
de choses à faire trop de travail alors
en laissant en jouant c'est des
arguments à la con c'est en jouant sur
le fait un médecin épidémiologiste bien
plutôt que de ça il a qu'à soigner enfin
mais on est tous les épidémiologistes
sont pas médecins et on a trop de choses
à faire faut pas se disperser et c'est
évidemment qui disait ça
des gens du cdc l'on dit de l' oms selon
dis donc des personnalités plutôt du
côté institutionnel mais experts
je ne connais pas ils sont dans des
dériveurs
j'en connais certains il ya un collègue
qui s'appelle eric mines cela l'a
expliqué à nos collègues du cdc a
expliqué mme y en ad'autres sait que
c'est compliqué de me souvenir de tout
ça c'est c'est pas de mauvaise volonté
mais connaître les noms de toutes les
personnes qui ont fait des déclarations
on retrouve ça dans des dériveurs
donc voilà c'est c'est quand même
intéressant de voir ça et alors un autre
quelque chose tout à fait extraordinaire
salon l'avez jamais vu c'est une des
grandes revues le land sept cas une
revue filles en quelques sortes
s'appelle lands est une fiction se
disent qu'ils début décembre ce sens
tout d'un coup inspiré en disant tiens
on va faire un éditorial sont l'ensemble
des
éditeurs de cette affection se disent
c'est pas quelqu'un qui l'a envoyé en
expliquant que
comme le choléra revient en haïti ce
qu'ils reviennent ce n'est pas tout à
fait ça
faire blâmer
accusés et
et voilà ne sert à rien donc
et à la fin justement il conclut en
disant que ou est peut-être plus tard ça
pourrait être intéressant de chercher
l'origine comme une sorte de curiosité
scientifique
vous avez une maladie qui est en train
de tuer des pleins demande déjà d'un
point de vue ne serait-ce que
judiciaire mais en plus on ne sait pas
comment elle est arrivée on sait pas
comment elle se propage nous on va pas
chercher ça on soigne les jambes ça
suffit hélas est dit par une des plus
grandes revues en tout cas la plus
grande revue sur les maladies
infectieuses au monde
et on va plus loin on va plus loin
encore en avance d'une case avec des
grandes des grandes revues leur
généraliste qui vont exactement dire la
même chose c'est voilà il ya une
finalement l'épidémie de choléra puis
une nouvelle épidémie de
d'accusation et c est là tout est repris
sur la recherche de boucs émissaires
dans les épidémies etc mais s'est repris
à propos d'haïti ce qui est pas du tout
le propos quand on cherche l'origine de
l'épidémie d'haïti
et donc ça va même jusqu'à donc j'ai
laissé cette partie finale où
l'auteur de cet article va même jusqu'à
dire que finalement ben c'est pas
tellement le vecteur le pauvre militaire
ils ont emmené le choléra les vrais
responsables c'est les haïtiens parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'accès à l'eau parce
qu'ils ont un mauvais assainissement
mais parce qu'ils ont des mauvaises
conditions de vie ils sont tout aussi
responsables
c'est ça qui est dit et c'est bon
particulièrement cruel quand même
ça le fait aussi une raison de chercher
et d'expliquer les choses c'est quand il
n'y a pas d'explication quand on dit
qu'il ya un mystère bien les gens vont
pas rester sur cette idée ça mystère est
une des conséquences possibles
c'est que il cherche d'autres causes
puisque ça arrive est mystérieusement
même les experts parleront ne sera pas
ces mystérieux et tout ça alors c'est
peut-être de la sorcellerie en haïti
elle vaut d'eau etc
et les prêtres vaudou ont été la cible
de lynchage
alors des lynchages qui sont qui sont
sévères et qui sont racontées les
personnes sont sorties de chez elle
caillasser tué à coups de machette et
brûlées dans la rue et plusieurs
dizaines de lynchage auront lieu
essentiellement dans les zones reculées
dans ce contexte de mystère
ouais internet y at il eu d'autres
hypothèses crédibles mise en avant et on
y va on y va
justement il fallait parce que tout ça
ça pose problème il faut pouvoir
trouver une explication et voilà
l'hypothèse qui aura été mise en avant
je vais en parler maintenant alors elle
est en mise en avant dès le 22 octobre
malheureusement dans le site de la
minustah n'existe plus mais andral frais
rixe a fait une capture d'écran ce pour
ça qu'il ya un petit commentaire en
anglais là là dessus c'est le c'est là
le premier message de la minustah qui
qui est produit dont immédiatement la
minustah s'est pas société de presse et
par reuters et pas la fp mais là ils ont
ils ont parlé ils ont fait un reportage
plus rapide pour dire quoi pour dire que
le premier cas de choléra selon le
ministère haïtien de la santé publique
et de la population a été recensé le 24
septembre dans le bas artibonite donc à
un endroit différent de là où ils se
trouvent les militaires et avant même
qu'ils aient la relève des militaires
sauf que cette information quand on pose
la question aux ministères etc mais
personne n'a cette information et
personne ne peut ne peut la confirmer
n'y avait pas de cas à ce moment là et
il avait aucun intérêt à les raconter
qu'il y avait du choléra avant je vous
reconnais entre deux side les népalais
les pauvres militaire en voyant ton par
le népal en général il ya eu un suivi
chez eux est ce qu'il ya eu des décès ce
qui a eu des
des gens qui sera bien la seule chose
qu'on peut savoir c'est une boîte noire
elle les enquêteurs haïtiens ont pas pu
rentrer évidemment le médecin a dit y a
pas de cas tout va bien alors il ya des
haïtiens qui travaillait dans le camp
qui disent non mais ils étaient tous
malades mais bon c'est pareil c'est des
gens ne peut on va pas leur faire
confiance c'est simple comme ça que les
choses sont vus c'est pas du tout ce que
je pense mais il faut vraiment écouter
tout le monde et je pense qu'ils avaient
des choses à dire mais ils ont été mis
de côté il ya peu une enquête jeudi sert
d'ailleurs et quand la mission des
nations unies a fait une enquête ils ont
regardé le registre et là on a eu une
terrible épidémie de constipation il n'y
a pas un soldats népalais qu'elle l'est
celle molle pendant les 15 jours de
prendre quinze premiers jours du séjour
longue à vidy l'audio non non c'est pas
qu'ils les ont gardées dix podiums c'est
que son registre n'est pas crédible vous
prenez la liasse dans ce camp il y avait
plus de 400 militaires il arrive dans un
pays qui est différent du leur là avec
un accès à l'eau qui de mauvaise qualité
etc etc quand on voyage on sait qu'à peu
près sur un voyage de 15 jours dans un
pays comme haïti ou comme l'afrique
alter tropicale on a à peu près une
chance sur cinq d'attraper la diarrhée
là il y en a 4 semble que personne n'ait
eu la diarrhée est juste pas crédible
mais c'est effectivement c'est le point
de départ ont dit y a pas eu de cas de
choléra dans le camp ci a pas de cas de
choléra dans le camp les latrines
peuvent être déversée d'ailleurs dans
ces cas là ya pas eu de choléra mais pas
nous donc ça vient pas de nous
alors l'hypothèse alternative donc nous
ramène vers le bas artibonite c'est une
zone d'estuaire avec des eaux saumâtres
et on sait que dans les eaux saumâtres
il y a des vibrio cholerae alors c'est
pas forcément les mêmes que ceux qui
donnent le choléra ce qui donne le
choléra c'est un clown tout à fait
particulier etc mais il ya quand même
des vibrio cholerae et il y a une
théorie qui a été développée en
particulier par un professeur américain
américain qui s'appelle rita colwell qui
qui a eu un succès extraordinaire qui a
été la présidente de la fondation de
l'académie des sciences américaine qui a
été conseillère de bagram barack obama
qu'à publier plein de choses et qui a
érigé cette cette théorie en paradigme
et qui a expliqué que finalement les
épidémies de choléra ça se passe d'abord
dans l'environnement avec le plancton
parce que le vibrio cholerae peuvent
peuvent se fixer sur le plancton il ya
des dans des conditions météorologiques
de chaleur etc une prolifération du
plancton prolifération des vibrio
cholerae et de la émergent des épidémies
donc la salle est drôlement bien pour
pour dire tiens dans quelque chose à
émerger dans le bas artibonite
on peut rajouter un élément que le cdc a
proposé assez rapidement qui est de dire
en plus le vibrion cholérique russe avec
qui venaient d'asie a pu arriver par le
ballast des bateaux le les bateaux quand
il voyage qui sont pas trop charger
remplissent leurs ballast dos au point
de départ et le vide au point d'arrivée
s'ils doivent embarquer deux des
chausseurs permet aux bateaux et aux
bateaux de pas de patong est trop fort
donc ça fait transporter des quantités
d'eau importante d'un endroit vers
l'autre avec cet os on peut avoir du
plancton des vibrio cholerae d'autres
choses
au des poissons des sur cinq est
d'ailleurs qu'on a des balistes en
méditerranée connu qu'à l'issue de deux
oui ça fait en fait ça fait rentrer des
espèces invasives
et on a même alors le l'histoire du
ballast rester quelques années sur le
site du cdc après ils ont trouvé que
c'était un peu relou il enlevait mais il
ya quand même on va trouver des articles
de cette époque là qui expliquent le
justement tout le danger qu'on peut
avoir avec ce ce type de choses mais
voilà simplement là dedans quelque chose
ne va pas c'est alors là c'est aussi
ralph rixe qui a trouvé cette photo je
ne sais pas où il a il a trouvé mal et
les tags et pas aux pannes american
health organization donc une série
d'experts examine
le une carte
on voit sur le sur le tableau on est
vraiment tout début de l'épidémie c'est
le 22 octobre et cette carte on peut
retrouver une carte très très proches
dans un rapport qui sont le 22 octobre
un rapport de situation de l'om s et
dallas ça va c'est évident on voit le
fleuve artibonite on voit la ville de
mirebalais dans le centre et on voit
bien que les cas sont tout le long du
fleuve artibonite donc si c'est la trace
violette c'est ça c'est la trace
violette autour de du fleuve artibonite
donc là il n'y a pas de souci quand on
comprend que le collet vibrio cholerae
voyage avec l'os et on peut imaginer
tout à fait que ça descend de mire bas
les vers la côte plus compliqué
d'imaginer que ça remonte y compris par
la route puisque la route qui va de
l'art type du bas de l'artibonite
verlingue admire ballet c'est une piste
elle est en mauvais état certains
endroits il ya pas beaucoup de trafic le
trafic principal du bas de l'artibonite
c'est vers port au prince donc c'est pas
la logique de dans l'autre sens et puis
ce qui va être intéressant c'est ce qui
va se passer après alors là site de la
pao qui était accessible et j'ai un
problème avec adobe et la mise à jour
d'adobe maintenant mais on a pas mal de
captures d'écran ralph rixe en a
d'autres à une autre période et on voit
que c'était un site interactif on
pouvait regarder l'évolution de
l'épidémie semaine après semaine et la
première semaine eh bien vous voyez que
le département du centre ne figure pas
parmi les départements atteint c'est
magique n'a pas haussé le même organisme
qui regardaient cette carte avec le
fleuve artibonite
mais là ils ont oublié c'est ballot
c'est et puis la semaine d'après on voit
les premiers cas arrivé dans le
département du centre ils ont quand même
occulté plusieurs milliers de cartes
même au minimum 2004
alors ça c'est quelque chose
déjà d'un qui inquiète un peu
ce que fait ocha est encore plus plus
évocateur
l'office de coordination des affaires
humanitaires de l'onu
ocha publié une première carte le 23
octobre donc vraiment au début de
l'épidémie et on voit bien que la ville
de mir balle et celle de lascahobas donc
dans département du centre sont touchés
et puis le reste du côté de la côte est
du bas artibonite
le 25 octobre la carte change un peu il
ya une couleur verte une couleur rose et
des villes qui était touché le 23 bon ça
c'est un peu bizarre et la couleur verte
dit basse et du choléra dans
l'artibonite la couleur rose dit c'est
du choléra autres par bond du choléra et
du choléra pourquoi changer de couleur
bon ça pas forcément un intérêt on
avance un peu petit à petit le on parle
d'épidémie de choléra pour le verre et
de communes affectées par le choléra
pour le rose c'est un peu pareil et puis
là le rose devient un peu plus
généralisé mais reste ce bar team
o'neill en verre et finalement à partir
du 28 octobre ce ver change de
signification à nouveau et ses zones de
début de l'épidémie de choléra en haïti
le reste est devenu les zones suivantes
dans quelque sorte c'est magique c'est
magique oui c'est c'est comme le
bonneteau vous ketty ok tu y es ap à la
fin ça sort et là ça se stabilisera là
dessus et ça donnera lieu à la
production d'une d'une figure qui
pareille commence par l'artibonite et
petit à petit on ne touchera finalement
le département du centre que sur la
troisième figure pourquoi pas alors que
c'était pas du tout le cas non ça a
commencé dans le département du centre
avant le département de l'artibonite
vous expliquer ça alors pour cette pour
cette figure j'étais présent le jour où
elle est sortie
c'était
après dans une dans la cellule de
coordination en quelque sorte de crise
en quelque sorte aimé y avait des boks
c'était dans des des des
oueds du préfabriqué parce que le palais
présidentiel était toujours par terre à
cause du tremblement de terre quelques
mois auparavant hélas comme le ministre
de la santé était pas très loin chez me
chercher je veux dire venez voir venez
voir et puis on regarde on dit aux mecs
de l'ocha mais ça c'est pas la vraie
histoire
féfé celui qui qui sait pas bien et tout
ça ils ont jamais changé évidemment pas
demandé des années ce truc là
à figurer comme étant l'explication du
choléra
et puis on va le trouver aussi dans des
articles c'est un article qui sort
quelques mois enfin l'année suivante bon
c'est sur des considérations sur le
choléra sur la vaccination là n'est pas
le propos mais ce qui est marrant c'est
là la fresque qui décrit l'épidémie et
l'appareil d'abord ça commence au 20
octobre tout ce qui est passé les 16 17
18 et 19 octobre il ya quand même
quelques centaines de cas de choléra
n'apparaissent pas d'ailleurs
disparaîtront de toutes les bases de
données
et puis ça commence bien sûr par
l'artibonite
et on va gagner une étape là dessus
c'est à dire que à ce moment là la
presse peut s'emparer du sujet et dire
bien le les experts disent que les
nations unies n'ont pas amené le choléra
puisqu'il était déjà là c'est cette
théorie avant a étudié la souche point
d'origine sans rien
annonces non sans rien là il n'avait pas
et surtout sans aucune preuve que le
choléra étaient déjà là du bon travail
journalistique du bon travail d'expert
aussi parce que les journalistes qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait là on est sûr sous
les robinets d'information des experts
c'est ça ils attendent c'est ça depuis
par exemple là on a un article du
guardian tout même un journal quand même
réputés sérieux on avait le new york
times aussi tout à l'heure et le
guardian interroge des scientifiques
alors qui va interroger va il va
interroger rita colwell évidemment il va
interroger un autre qui boc a beaucoup
travaillé avec rita colwell quel
professeur david sac et qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont lui raconter ils vont raconter que
c'est en fait c'était dormant dans le
delta de l'artibonite qui l'a fait chaud
qui a eu le tremblement de terre qui a
eu un cyclone alors le cyclone il a bien
eu lieu mais il a eu lieu trois semaines
après le début de l'épidémie il ya eu
déjà cette espèce de piques que je vous
ai montré donc ils vont expliquer ça ils
vont expliquer leurs théories et ça
deviendra la vérité scientifique au mois
de novembre à la fin du mois de novembre
il n'y a plus aucun doute tout le monde
est convaincu que cette histoire de
népalais s'était de la foutaise ce qui
est important c'est ce que disent les
scientifiques
qui est d'ailleurs corroborée par les
cartes produites maintenant par les
nations unies etc
ça a commencé dans l'artibonite et
scellier oro au climat et à d'autres
problèmes comme ces questions internet
ne voit-il pas de la désinformation là
où il n'y a que de l'incompétence
alors on va voir on va il ya des choses
effectivement pourrait penser que alors
c'est quand même embêtant parce que là
on est sur les principaux experts sur le
domaine et je n'entrerai peut-être à
nice besoin il a déjà il a été muté ou
je ne sais pas où loyaux services elle
est pas parti
je me dis pas ce qu'elle fait mais je
vais montrer effectivement c'est
important je me suis beaucoup posé la
question et donc on va trouver vraiment
des mensonges des falsifications y
compris chez les scientifiques en avance
on va le voir alors évidemment dans ce
contexte là quand avec
l'aide de des collègues de msf ont fait
savoir que ben non ça c'est pas passé là
alors à msf sont fait pourrir le les ce
qu'il de msf france qui qui ont sorti
l'information avec moi ils sont faits
pour rire parce que par leurs collègues
qui étaient ceux d'autres sections de
msf qui disent mais ça va pas du tout ça
a été apporté ça commençait à saint marc
au bord de la mer ça a été partie
apportée par les bateaux cet
épidémiologiste français je sais pas ce
qu'ils racontent et c'est parce que les
gens ont fini par le croire
donc le truc est sorti et il est sorti
il a fait du bruit quand même parce que
les journalistes nous ont compris qu'il
y avait quelque chose de bizarre et ça
fait du bruit dans la presse
internationale la bbc le washington post
a repris l'information
hélas a obligé le même temps après moi
j'ai fait mon rapport à toute fin du
mois de novembre donc 2010 donc à la fin
de ma mission je suis rentré j'ai écrit
mon rapport deux jours après je les
envoyer à msf à l'om s est à l'ambassade
de france pour qu'ils le diffuser
au niveau 2 du gouvernement haïtien et
les trois en fuite et
3a pour l'un pour là je suis assez enfin
j'ai dit oui il faut le faire pour l'om
est bien sûr ils ont diffusé ces partis
un peu partout dans les nations unies
regardez ce rapport mon dieu c'est ça va
pas du tout et pour le l'ambassade de
france dès lors qu'ils ont passés aux
haïtiens évidemment tout y est les
jonathan katz par exemple avait avait le
rapport au bout de 48 heures
et donc le secrétaire général de l'onu
là commencent à trouver que ça va ça va
pas bien et il prévoit donc il il dit
maintenant que c'est important de
chercher là l'origine c'est vraiment
important les haïtiens le mérite et il
va nommer un panel indépendant pour le
faire et ça c'est intéressant le la
méthode du panel indépendant parce que
on a encore ce genre de choses ce genre
de pratique s'est nommé un panel
indépendant mais quand même on le mans
bien alors comment comment se constituer
ce panel ban ki moon va demander
officiellement à la directrice de l'ot
de l' oms margaret chan de trouver les
meilleurs experts dans tous les domaines
qui ont lien avec ça pour qu'ils aillent
enquêtait sur le terrain lors de leurs
déclarations s'ils ont des intérêts à
gauche à droite ou pas du tout je
suppose que oui mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse je vais sur un site ça m'a
inquiété tout de suite j'ai vu les noms
parce que j'ai fait je vais sur un site
s'appelle pubmed sur les publications
médicales et là j'ai réussi à reproduire
à peu près ce qu'on pouvait avoir donc
j'ai mis les noms des membres du panel
et j'ai rajouté rita colwell et puis le
choléra donc qu'est-ce que les membres
du panel ce que les membres du panel ont
un lien avec rita colwell à propos du
choléra et là vous verrez en fait il ya
une vingtaine 27 articles et vous verrez
que les trois scientifiques du parade du
panel médecin ou microbiologiste non
seulement travaillent avec rita colwell
non plus défendre les mêmes thèses que
rita colwell ce sont des articles qui
disent exactement
choléra y viennent l'environnement et
c'est bien choisit alors la quatrième
personne du panel est une ingénieure
elle l'écrit pas ça l'a pas écrit sur le
choléra donc on va pas la retrouver
là-dedans mais c'est ce panel là qui qui
va enquêter et qui va devoir arbitrer
entre la théorie de rita colwell celle
de david sacs et les résultats je dis
pas que c'est une théorie moi parce que
c'est quand même le résultat d'une
investigation rita colwell reste dans
aux états unis pour le faire moi non je
suis sur le terrain ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose
et david sac justement des fois que donc
c'est un grand spécialiste depuis on
s'est rabiboché n'y a pas de passe qui
lui là il a jeté l'épongé mais il est
nommé enfin
discrètement par l'onu pour faire un
rapport sur mon rapport et il conclut
que j'ai dû me tromper parce que ça peut
pas avoir démarré du côté de mails parce
que c'est allé tellement vite lui part
du principe qu'il n'y avait pas de
soldats malades c'était peut
éventuellement quelques uns
symptomatique ça ne suffit pas et je
suis totalement d'accord s'il n'y a pas
de soldats malades ça ne marche pas mais
je la seule chose que j'imagine c'est
que les militaires peuvent n'a pas avoir
dit qu'il avait des soldats malades
qu'ils avaient une épidémie et c'est ce
que lui n'a pas n'a pas imaginé et il
dit sinon le fait que ça se multiplient
comme ça en descendant la rivière que ça
explose est juste impossible
d'arette
je vais la reformuler est ce que l'on
aimé ça un petit peu maquillé les choses
pour éviter le trouble à l'ordre public
si tout le monde allait s'en prendre aux
miliciens ou militaires pardon ça aurait
pu être pire alors il ya eu pire que les
lynchages c'est quand même compliqué je
reconnais il y a eu des manifestations
au mois de novembre en particulier à la
mi novembre des émeutes il ya même eu un
mort en spa militaire qui est mort quand
vous mettez des militaires face à des
manifestants c'est quand même ils sont
les militaires sont du bon côté du fusil
re
français cette affaire s'inscrit donc il
il y a bien eu un mort bien sûr les gens
ont protesté
mais il protesté d'autant plus qu'on ne
cherchait pas la cause
après comme il ya on était aussi en
période électorale et encore des émeutes
après c'était compliqué la situation
était très compliquée mais moi je veux
bien entendre que c'est ne pas dire le
problème c'est ne pas mettre de l'huile
sur le feu c'est bien mais laissez les
gens alors qu'ils savent bien ce qui
s'est passé dans ce sentiment
d'injustice ne fait qu' attiser les
choses aussi et là c'est une des
discussions qu'on a eues avec msf et on
a déduit que il valait mieux dire mais
c'est une très bonne question alors ce
rapport du panel il sort quelques mois
plus tard
entre temps j'ai juste eu deux coups de
téléphone du dudit de leader du panel
alejandro cravioto
je suis même pas sûr je vais passer
plein de choses j'ai même pas sûr qu'ils
les aient passé à ses collègues et que
conclut le panel alors ils ont vraiment
chercher ils ont vraiment chercher dans
l'artibonite ils ont rien trouvé ils
sont obligés de dire que ça a bien
commencé à mais c'était et pouvait pas
faire autrement et donc il le dit ça
commençait à un mail ces îles un certain
nombre des photos que je vous ai montré
delà de la fosse septique et tout ça
vienne de ce panel donc en particulier
toute la partie assainissement était
clair ils disent que c'est
drôlement au sujet du coin de d'asie du
sud 1 sont même trompé une petite faute
de frappe ils disent qu'elle est
identique à celle du alors c'est pas le
génome total mais avec déjà des
techniques assez bonne à celle du népal
en 2009 il se trouve que c'est népal en
2010 et mais ils disent ils ont répondu
que c'était juste une faute de frappe et
puis donc que c'était lié à l'activité
humaine et s'affrontent entendre aux
matières fécales
et donc ça commence à amasser liez avec
d'une souche d'asie du sud c'est lié aux
matières fécales mais ils vont pas plus
loin et ils ressortent finalement
l'histoire
à la confluence de facteurs confluence
de facteurs les haïtiens n'étaient pas
immunisés isaac bull la fota pas de bol
exactement c'est écrit en bas c'est ça
c'est écrit c'est la faute à personne
c'est la volonté délibérée de personnes
donc et les facteurs ces blés voilà les
gens pas immunisés mauvais accès à l'oms
a lancé l'assainissement ils utilisent
ils travaillent dans les rizières enfin
tous ces trucs là avec simplement un des
éléments qui est le numéro trois sur la
liste qui disent que le canal et le le
delta de l'artibonite constitue un
environnement optimal pour la croissance
rapide de vibrio cholerae comme une
sorte de bouillon de culture et ça ils
le disent comme ça ils n'ont pas la
preuve mais pour eux c'est l'explication
l'explication d'ailleurs qui avait été
rejeté par david sac mais c'est une
condamnation à mort d'haïti parce que
tout d'un coup ils ont milieu de leur
truc un endroit où un pathogène terrible
arrive à accroître dans l'environnement
l'opération du saint-esprit je vous
coupe je suis désolé question internet
il vous a consulté au sujet du coc vide
genre les pouvoirs publics voulaient de
l'elysée c'est ça la
grc pour sage et la cravate j'étais
juste à l'elysée l'a discuté avec la
conseillère de du pp oui c'est ça deux
des manuels macro dire qu'on m'a
consulté j'essaye de parler un petit peu
de quelques trucs là dessus de faire
passer effectivement un certain nombre
de messages
donc on en est là donc cette histoire ça
c'est important cette confluence de
facteurs c'est pas que ça ça rappelle ça
rappelle les cigaretiers qu'il est les
fabricants de cigarettes qui pour se
dédouaner ont fait faire des recherches
sur
le comme les cancers dus à l'amiante le
radon et d'autres choses comme ça ou sur
les
les néonicotinoïdes
pour les abeilles on va chercher basique
qui s'appelle le varois où on va
chercher le frelon asiatique est à
chaque fois finalement la communauté
sont ils formés on met plein d'études en
cours et aux filles fini par dire on
peut pas trancher bon là c'est quand
même un peu gros parce que ces facteurs
là le fait que les gens et moi ça me
rappelle quand même aussi jeu c'est une
image à l'aide d'un professeur de santé
de deux
de
justice comment s'appelle le droit qui a
fini par dire bon moi j'ai eu un
accident j'ai renversé une vieille dame
et puis puis tant pis toute façon je ne
veux pas je veux pas m'en occuper donc
et tant pis si la vie d'homme si elle a
une fracture c'est aussi parce qu'elle
avait de l'ostéoporose et que ça lui
dévié parce qu'elle était vieille elle a
pas traversé assez vite donc c'est un
peu un peu ça
je vais continuer
alors puisque la question était posée
là on va sur la malversation
scientifique
voilà on va on va sur alors première
chose
rita colwell deux ans après sur un
article alors si l'article sort deux ans
après c'est qu'il était en cours de
préparation c'est il faut du temps quand
même les études en cours alors rita
colwell continue avec son idée d'un de
facteurs de circonstance
confluence de circonstance avec le
tremblement de terre c'est pas la même
zone mais c'est pas grave le un été très
chaud
le cyclone tomas bon il arrive à un peu
après mais elle mais l'engin peut être
un peu tout ça on va voir d'ailleurs
comment elle le mélange pas assez c'est
assez intéressant je me fais l'avocat du
diable sait c'est peut-être juste de
l'incompétence pas de la malversation
elle est alors on va on va avancer et on
va voir un exemple il y en a beaucoup
d'autres je peux pas les tous les
montrer voilà l'article quel sort alors
déjà on voit dans les hauteurs un
certain alejandro cravioto alors on est
dans une histoire où il ya un arbitre
qui arbitre un match de foot puis de
temps en temps voilà arbitres qui prend
qui va dans l'équipe du psg qui va
marquer des buts aussi avec le psg
contre l'om si on veut par exemple
généralement on fait pas ça
généralement ça arrive souvent j'ai
l'impression
des histoires comme ça
beaucoup de temps pour étudier une
histoire et et trouver tout ce qui s'est
passé faut avoir été au coeur de
l'histoire emaf lui quand même du temps
pour c'est un condensé et c'est pour ça
que sur la comète j'ai moins de deux
facilités à voir tout ce qui se passe
j'espère que le petit à petit je vais
essayer de comprendre
l'introduction ça c'est important quand
on lit l'introduction d'un article on
sait où on va alors là c'est le choléra
c'est une maladie est une maladie des
pays en développement c'est les pauvres
non et puis là plusieurs lignes sur le
tremblement de terre les répliques et c'
est l' été très chaud juste après et au
milieu du déblaiement des
détritus arrive le premier cas de
choléra le 21 octobre
2000 2010 et puis ensuite ça commence à
diffuser puis un ouragan et ça fait une
grande épidémie donc on démarre le
choléra au milieu du déblaiement des
détritus donc très bien et il ya une
figure dans cet article une figure qui
présente les zones de prélèvement la
situation est un peu bizarre cette
figure mais moi j'ai la chance d'avoir
une épouse et coucou marty d' une les
médecins les ophtalmos les institutrices
mais elle a aussi un dea de géographie
de la santé et c'est elle qui me fait
les cartes et med et la maintenance
aussi une thèse de santé publique et
elle voit cette carte elle se dit
celle-là je l' ai déjà vu et je sais pas
je dis aux gens sur sur le net est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu cette carte la
réponse est oui ils ont déjà vu cette
carte parce que j'ai déjà présenté mais
c'est pas facile cette carte là c'est
celle là
c'est celle là alors là on est sur un
article sur le choléra c'est la parler
d'un article sur le tremblement de terre
ce qui est là en rose plus ou moins vif
semblent être des les zones atteintes
par le choléra mais en fait ce sont les
zones atteintes par le tremblement de
terre et surtout ce qui est caché
derrière une espèce de cartouches où il
ya les lieux des prélèvements est quand
même très intéressant à lire parce qu on
y apprend donc c'est le début de
l'épidémie à
138 morts je voulais déjà dit mais on y
apprend plus que l'épidémie a lieu très
loin de la zone du tremblement de terre
dont ça viendrait contredire
l'introduction c'est quand même une
bonne idée que de cacher à la fois le ce
qui était écrit l'appui le ocz a aussi
ça faisait mauvais genre là on est quand
même dans de la malversation
scientifique c'est plus de
l'incompétence ou alors c'est répondre à
la question internet at il une intime
conviction sur les motivations de ce
camouflage
je pense que c'est on est on est sur
deux de la psychologie c'est j'ai quand
même beaucoup regardé il ya eu d'autres
scientifiques sont partis en bibine en
cours d'épidémies j'ai beaucoup regardé
ce cas vous pouvez pu faire rita colwell
david sac par exemple lui il a arrêté
tout de suite quand il a vu qu'il
s'était planté il a fermé sa gueule et
puis il est parti sur autre chose et il
l'a fait très bien et voilà on se voit
et on s'apprécie rita colwell elle est
restée sur son truc en 2017 je n'ai pas
regardé depuis elle continue à raconter
ça même histoire sans nom devienne d'une
seconde d'ailleurs on continue dans les
malversations toujours l'équipe de rita
colwell et là c'est comme on a fini par
trop dire que le le cyclone avait eu
lieu après le début de l'épidémie que
c'était trop visible eh bien elle nous
sort ça elle nous sort que pendant l'été
qui assure précédé cette année là il ya
eu un été très chaud alors la cds la
comparaison de la température par
rapport aux températures moyennes des
années précédentes la différence et d'un
degré d'un demi degré elles mêmes elle
deviendra zéro au niveau du mois de
novembre au moment du pic de du premier
pic de l'épidémie octobre novembre
pratiquement plus de différence mais
s'il ya surtout en septembre un pic de
précipitations très importantes et là où
il ya quelqu'un qui nous dit sur le chat
qui a écrit choléra sur les deux cartes
j'ai pas coulé fait référence oui et a
écrit choléra sur les deux cartes je
reviens en arrière là et a écrit choléra
mais quand on regarde la légende ce qui
est rose c'est les clans les camps de
personnes déplacées et quand on va sur
l'autre et c'est plus écrit parce que
c'est caché par le cartouche donc c'est
là c'est devenu du choléra là c'est le
début du choléra mais la légende le rose
indique pas le choléra mais indiquent
les camps de déplacés
puis pas de souci
donc le pic de précipitations en
septembre 2010 là on a la puce à
l'oreille on se dit quand même la
cocotte la tendance à nous embarquer
surtout moi j'avais fait l'investigation
j'avais posé la question aux gens dans
la plaine de l'artibonite est ce qu'ils
ont été inondés machin tout ça y est et
on refait les calculs on regarde enfin
on récupère les données ce les données
de la nasa ont refait les calculs on ne
trouve plus haut pic de plus de
précipitations on écrit à la revue qui
accepte de publier notre notre lettre
qui demande une réponse dans la réponse
rita colwell noie le poisson en disant
mais regardez quand même il trouve un
peu plus de cas en dans l'été dans fin
en septembre 2010 2 puis 2 puis en
septembre 2010 que de l'en réseau des
années mais c'est à peine plus c'est
moins de 200 alors comme sur le sol à le
grave précédent ce deux précédentes et
allons-y maintenant et c'est cette
histoire de d'élimination du choléra
évidemment au bout d'un moment quand
même les différentes institutions sont
dits faut quand même faire quelque chose
on veut faire un plan d'élimination du
choléra on l'a ici en anglais en
français on peut le trouver assez
facilement
et qu'est ce qui est écrit au tout début
du plan résumé stratégique l'élimination
du choléra sur l'île d'hispaniola se
traduit par l'interruption de la
transmission cependant la bactérie étant
dans l'environnement des cas sporadiques
sont toujours diagnostic et oui tout ce
qui a été expliqué tout ce truc là il
restait même si maintenant on comprend
que c'est les népalais cette histoire
d'environnement qui était une sorte de
milieux de culture et rester et ça veut
dire qu'on peut pas s'en débarrasser le
plan il demande 2,2 milliards pour faire
la santé
le ramassage des ordures l'eau etc et
encore il ya pas assez mais il ne donne
aucun espoir de s'en débarrasser est
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de deux
études sont faites pour dire ça va
continuer si on fait rien de spécial ça
va continuer par exemple sur le
département de l'ouest se trouve port au
prince on a comme ça on nous prévoit une
continuité de d'épidémie un peu en début
de la saison des pluies en fin de saison
des pluies
pendant advitam eternam
sauf sauf si on vaccine on va y venir
alors cette histoire l'a fait que bondé
quand même des victimes portent plainte
fin essayent d'obtenir un procès ça se
passe aux etats unis le gouvernement
américain
va ça va au procès dit de toute façon
vous n'avez pas le droit de d'accuser
l'onu l'onu à une immunité totale ne
peut rien faire elonu gagne ces procès
puisque
on n'a pas le droit d'aller au fond sur
la forme on ne peut pas accuser l'onu de
quoi que ce soit c'est au dessus de
toutes les lois c'est à l'onu de voir
comment réparer les choses mais l'onu ne
fait rien et alors c'est à l'intérieur
même de l'onu que va se passer une
rébellion en quelque sorte et en
particulier une personne prof de droit
donc à new york avec un australien
d'origine qui est rapporteur spécial
pour l'extrême pauvreté et les droits de
l'homme et il va incendié le en fait le
bureau des affaires légales de l'onu et
le ban ki moon et son service pour donc
faire ce rapport si vous êtes intéressé
c'est vraiment un truc passionnant à
lire de voir comment les choses sont
dites et puis les arguments sont
finalement très très fort c
le c'est moralement défendable c'est
politiquement désastreux etc c'est
vraiment ça qui est écrit et c'est le
voilà c'est la position de philip alston
quelque part ça marche
puisque dans les semaines qui suivent
ban ki-moon accepte il va bientôt
quitter le pouvoir
en quelque sorte il veut terminer son
deuxième mandat et il accepte de
s'adresser au monde en doc à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies et dire en
anglais en français et en créole haïtien
donc je veux le dire simplement français
au nom des nations unies je vais vous le
dire très clairement nous nous excusons
auprès du peuple haïtien s'excuse de
quoi pour le rôle de l'onu dans
l'épidémie mme sans expliquer quel était
le rôle et pour ne pas en avoir fait
assez et donc il promet en même temps
400 millions de dollars
200 millions pour arrêter l'épidémie de
choléra a finalement c'était possible
temps après en six ans après on est en
deux fins 2016 et 200 millions pour les
victimes ce qui fait pas beaucoup et
beaucoup de victimes comme et les 400
millions en fait
pendant longtemps c'était 10 millions
maintenant c'est passé à 20 millions
parce que les états unis on rajoutait 10
millions récemment et ce qui est
intéressant au mas la liste des
donateurs sur ce sur ce site et jusqu'à
il n'y a pas très longtemps le népal
avait donné
237 $ j'ai dis pas deux cent trente sept
mille dollars jeudi se bat dit à 137
millions de dollars 237 $ ils ont trouvé
que c'était pas beaucoup ils ont rajouté
5000 donc c'est maintenant 5237 dollars
c'est la contribution du népal a le
règlement de ce problème quand même où
leurs militaires avaient un rôle très
important puisqu'ils n'ont quand même
rien dit sur le choléra il avait le
système de sanitaires qui était qu'à
l'habitude il y était pour quelque chose
5237 dollars s'il ya eu 50 mille morts
par exemple ses 10 ans
moore
et puis finalement ça c'est un article
récent il n'y a toujours pas eu d'argent
qui est arrivé aux victimes et a eu un
peu d'argent qui a été utilisée pour
quelques actions communautaires à droite
à gauche
mais rien pour les victimes
on avance un peu c'est aussi la
désinformation peut venir aussi du fait
que on à faire un business est-ce que ça
se pourrait être une source de
désinformation
alors on va justement toujours cette
période de 2016 le cyclone matthew
arrive c'est la fin de l'année c'est la
période des cyclones au mois d'octobre 4
octobre énormes cyclones il va frapper
l'extrémité de la pointe sud d'haïti
mais frappée violemment et le 14 octobre
dijon a pris a déjà un premier un
premier article premier reportage sur
une véritable épidémie de choléra mais
dans un dans une vallée relativement
isolé et finalement le cyclone les avais
complètement isolé donc ils ont dû se
dépatouiller avec le choléra et ça fait
quand même du dégât mais ça reste
quelque chose de très localisés et se
pose la question des risques de flambée
de choléra après matthew et il y a à ce
moment là je reçois deux collègues de
l'unicef et de aussi une collecte de
l'om est ce un petit rapport de quelques
pages
qui fait qu'ils préparent une réunion
qu'il va avoir lieu le 19 octobre 1 à
port au prince moi je suis en france
donc je peux pas y aller mais il me
demande un peu mon avis à propos d'un
modèle qui qui apparaît sur ce rapport
donc il ya là c'est les premières pages
du rapport qui disent bon bain
conformément au modèle en annexe on peut
penser qu'il peut se passer ça ou ça et
voilà le modèle est donc ce modèle il en
fait une classe haïti en trois parties
en quelque sorte la péninsule sud qui
qui est en bas et qui va être touchée
très rapidement par le choléra et puis
il prévoit une
quelque chose au milieu du côté de
l'artibonite et enfin ouvert c'est le
sait le nord un peu plus tard on regarde
ça sue avec deux collègues le professeur
jean godard et le docteur stanislas
robots des pistes à nice tu as trop
bonne elle m'a dit
et ça je le connais c'est un peu comme
martin m'avait dit cette carte j'ai déjà
vu lui c'est les courbes qu'il a déjà
mis fin dans la nuit aux graphiques
c'est ça dont classe et c'est lui qui
dit ça je les ai déjà vus et pourquoi il
les a déjà vus parce qu'en fait c'est
lui qui les a faites
il a fait ses courbes et en fait il les
a faites à propos d'un article qu'on
avait fait quelques années avant pour
décrire le espèce de dons de choc on
l'avait décrit de manière un peu plus
mathématique que ce que je vous ai
montré avec des déclassifications
hiérarchique ascendante bref et on avait
un des profils d'épidémie différents
selon la localisation qu'on voit sur
cette carte mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder les clusters b c et e
sur ce truc là et on voit que ce sont
effectivement les mêmes c'est exactement
la même construction
sauf que là c'est cluster 1 2 3 hélas
ces classes a b c d donc les jambes le
titre a changé la légende et la
signification a changé et puis une
petite histoire de pointillés regarder
la courbe verte les convives verte sur
notre article elle s'arrêtait en eau et
là il fallait la faire descendre c'est
donc ils ont rajouté quand on regarde de
près c'est pas tout à fait le même verre
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
pointillés histoire de deux voilà de
braire qu'ils font pas très très bien
leur boulot j'ai essayé de savoir d'où
venait ce modèle c'est la pao qui
l'avait amené mais ça venait d'une
université américaine
j'irai pas y faire mes études j'ai pas
su laquelle s'était j'y vais j'ai pas eu
le nom des personnes alors ça ça m'amène
à ouvrir une parenthèse et on va venir
un peu sur un truc plus le plus récent
vous souvenez la cia quelques jours ce
débat après entre emmanuel macron et les
scientifiques est ce qu'il a eu raison
d'eux pas confiné fin janvier dont je
parle pas de cet aspect là mais cet
aspect là à amener à un certain nombre
de députés à dire mais non pas du tout
parce que disaient les scientifiques
prévoyez une vague épidémique au mois de
février ça a pas eu lieu on a gagné du
temps etc et les gens dans un certain
nombre de députés ont dit venant pas
vrai regardez le modèle que castex nous
a présenté en
donc le c'était le 28 janvier dans une
commission avec à la fois les
parlementaires le sénat et les députés
je sais pas s'ils étaient ensemble ou
face mais il a présenté un truc est
effectivement cette c'est écrit là je
n'arrive pas à lire mais ces projections
non ça va ses écrits projection donc sur
ce qui va se passer
et les députés disent non mais vous
voyez finalement les projections étaient
pas si calamiteuse que ça mais elle
montrait que ça allait augmenter
fortement en mars ce qui s'est passé et
le problème c'est que cette figure alors
il y avait une collègue député killer
qui avait l'original parce que c'est moi
qui lui avais envoyé cet original parce
que ce sas et là c'est la figure delà de
la projection on voit mieux
effectivement on voit donc une courbe
noire une courbe qui marquait total on
comprend pas très bien avec la légende
présenter castex c'est ce que castex a
présenté le variant anglais à +0
35 sûr que c'est plus à 33 sur un peu
loin et régale 1.4 on comprend pas on
pense que c'est le pointillé parce que
le lip aude le scénario maximal séance
1,65 c'est la rouge et l'autre c105 donc
on pense que les trois trucs ne
comprends plus à quoi sert la la courbe
blanche et en fait quand on regarde de
très près vous voyez que ce traits
pointillés été rajoutés c'est juste
d'ailleurs c'est pas une courbe
épidémique donc on est un peu sur le
même mécanisme que ce que je viens de
montrer pour pour le choléra en haïti
est la figure d'origine et bien j'aurai
du mal moi je n'avais pas connaissance
cela la figure d'origine c'est moins que
les fêtes c'est moi qui l'ait fait
quand je suis allé voir castex voilà le
27 janvier et juste pour lui expliquer
parce qu'à ce moment là il y avait une
discussion sur le
sur le fait qu'on ne voyait rien
apparaître
alors que nous on disait attention le
variant le variant le variant mais on
nous répondait mais ça bouge pas c'était
juste pour montrer qu'il faut du temps
pour que ça bouge espérons que j'avais
fait une sorte de figure à visée
pédagogique avec le bleu bleu la
solution mondiale voilà ce qu'on voit à
l'écran le rouge le variant et le noir
la somme des deux et on voit que il faut
du temps pour que ça donne quelque chose
mais vous y trouvez pas la ligne
pointillée vous ne trouvez pas
d'ailleurs c'est pas le même titre c'est
pas une projection c'était pas du tout
ça et donc ça c'est vraiment le remettez
mois à l'écran la coupe trafic etc des
pointillés fait pas un mannequin la
voilà
c'est quand même beau de voir en haut à
gauche un drapeau français avec sa wii
c'est nos impôts à lhassa a pas coûté
très cher
et donc on a les deux on aller 2-1 à
côté alors à côté de l'autre voilà et
donc si ça
ça date de ce matin voilà mediapart a
mis la main sur cette histoire là a
commencé à interroger les députés si on
hume interrogé ben moi j'ai dit aux
médias partisans seul truc c'est bien
ben c'est pas mal et moi j'ai expliqué
que ben oui c'est moi je voilà ce que
j'avais donné quel était l'objectif et
c'est
après
discussions maintenant entre les députés
le gouvernement sur cette histoire là
c'est pas à moi d'intervenir disons que
d'un point de vue scientifique c'est pas
ce qu'on attend d'un scientifique on n'a
pas le droit de faire ça mais dans les
discussions entre politiques j'espérais
qu'il n'est pas seul dans le dos
pourquoi ils font sincérité s'était
rassuré les parlementaires s'étaient
c'est hyper compliqué on comprends pas
parce que en même temps mediapart
explique ça j'en sais rien je ne vais
pas assister à la présentation et ses
députés qui explique à mediapart que
finalement castex c'est plutôt favorable
au confinement alors j'ai pas je
comprends pas très bien je comprend pas
qui on sait pas qui l'a fait moi je sais
ce que j'ai remis au premier ministre
je sais maintenant ce qu'il a présenté
aux députés
entre les deux qui a fait ça je pense
pas que ce soit lui qui sont amusés à
scanner un truc et c'est est-ce que
c'est lui qui a demandé à ce qu'il soit
fait ça j'en sais rien mais quand même
ça fait pas très sérieux
surtout corée du mans je finis ma
parenthèse et je reviens en sur le un
peu la fin de cette histoire du choléra
2016 quand même une question qui
s'intéressent de cyprès au choléra en
haïti parce que le cyclone mathieu à
peine terminée le 4 octobre déjà le 7
octobre dans le guardian il y avait un
article un article avec
expliquant qu'il fallait absolument
lancer une grande campagne de
vaccination
alors on voit tout de suite que cet
article
on voit déjà sur la page que la
fondation bill et melinda gates est dans
le coup et en fait les deux auteurs de
l'article se revendique de la fondation
bill et melinda gates mais pourquoi pas
après tout on peut on peut tout à fait
imaginer que
ça les intéresse individuellement 2 sur
ce truc là
simplement
finalement cette campagne a eu lieu
cette campagne de vaccination un million
de doses sont parties relativement vite
finalement elle a été organisée
un mois après la fin du cyclone comme
quoi on peut aller très vite pour
organiser une campagne de vaccination
massive et dans des conditions
extrêmement compliqué
et c'est le gavi c'est la global
alliance for vaccines for vaccines
immunisation donc qui est un partenariat
public privé qui décide d'allouer les
fonds et les vaccins en quelque sorte ce
partenariat public-privé le principal
acteur privé c'est la fondation bill et
melinda gates
ça ça m'intéresse a fini par
m'intéressait et je recherche y compris
dans les publications médicales et il ya
une success story qui racontait dans les
publications médicales dans une revue
s'appelle vaccine tout à fait sérieux
aussi et c'est la success story de
avicole le vaccin contre le choléra un
vaccin contre le choléra qui est produit
en corée et là il ya une explication sur
finalement les différentes strates qui
interviennent dans la à la fois dans les
décisions politiques dans la production
du vaccin dans le
l'attribution du vaccin dans tous ces
trucs là et sur chacune des strates on
va retrouver la fondation bill et
melinda gates plus ou moins visibles
plus ou moins directement
et en particulier et ça c'est peut-être
la surprise on les retrouve dans la
strate de la production du vaccin et là
on va alors c'est pas c'est pas expliqué
dans l'article pour la production du
vaccin mais il ya un biologique ce et
quand on regarde biologics
d'abord il vient de se présenter ils
sont allés à plusieurs reprises se
présenter à la global ça se forçant
choléra contrôle qui est quelque chose
qui est coordonnée par l' oms mais avec
un appui financier de la fondation bill
et melinda gates là ils sont venus
présenter en 2018 leur leur entreprise
alors c'est une vraie entreprise c'est
pas c'est pas un truc
charitative caritatif ou quoi que ce
soit c'est une entreprise pour faire de
l'argent je me fais l'avocat du diable
on peut faire de l'argent mais où on a
aussi envie d'aider non mais on est tout
à fait d'accord on est tout à fait
d'accord on peut avoir envie d'aider
faire de l'argent
comment comme on a envie d'aider on se
met dans les instances de décision gavi
comme on a envie d'aider on est de l'om
est ce comme on a envie d'aider on
demande aux scientifiques on paye des
scientifiques pour faire des études on
va y arriver mais après ça peut quand
même tombé sur certaines dérives alors
par exemple
si je saute voilà je suis tombé sur cet
article celui là et il est magnifique
qu'il faut le lire si vous avez le temps
c'est dans une revue financière c'est en
fait ça explique que cette boîte à oeufs
biologiques c'est en fait elles
dépendent c'est une des boîtes d'un
portefeuille d'un fonds d'investissement
qui est cogérée par la jp morgan chase
bank et la fondation bill et melinda
gates et la suite de l'article
expliquant même que de là ça rapporte un
max et en particulier cette histoire de
vaccins cd rentabilité extrêmement
importantes ne se souvient plus des
chiffres ne s'était plus de 30 % l'an et
c'est un truc qui qui a vraiment eu un
succès terrible l'idée c'est de faire
des vaccins pas trop cher et d'en vendre
énormément et donc la haïti un million
de personnes à vacciner c'était c'était
une bonne idée vous couvrir vous coupe
je me suis l'avocat du diable ils ont
vraiment besoin d'un avocat oui
c'est des paris risqués d'investir pour
la recherche de vaccins vont n'est pas
content on prend moins de risques quand
on est quand on est bien placé pour
demander sa pré qualification parce que
l'on aime s comme m est
redevable mais de toute façon quand on a
en plus des équipes scientifiques qui
vont faire les enquêtes les choses qui
sont les études qui sont intéressantes
et finalement et en plus il s'agit pas
de mettre au point un vaccin et
s'agissait de le rendre moins cher le
vaccin existait déjà il s'agissait de le
simplifier et c est par exemple ou de
prendre des petits flacons en verre de
le faire en plastique c'est une bonne
idée
c'est très pragmatique parce que c'est
moins lourd plus facile à transporter ça
casse pas etc etc donc après le petit
problème le vaccin n'est pas d'une très
très grande efficacité
il est autour il ya 2 c'est un vaccin
par la bouche de prisa
minimum 15 jours d'intervalle
donne une une
ne citer une efficacité de l'ordre de 60
et quelques pour cent
ça c'est les résultats
d'études randomisées en double aveugle
des études de cohorte alors on va voir
ce que ça peut donner comme dérive parce
que c'est ça et je vais finir ma
présentation sur celle-là de dérive vous
pouvoir passer en deuxième partie oui
désolé si un peu long mais aussi
d'accord s'est traduit notez donc en
fait malgré tout
les choses qu'on a pu dire sur l'onu
stanislas rodez et moi enfin surtout moi
au début on est quand même on a été
sollicités et on a sollicité l'unicef
est ensemble on a proposé une stratégie
qui ressemble beaucoup à ce qu'on
appelle maintenant le contact tracking
et c'est donc des équipes chaque fois
qu'il y avait un malade des équipes se
rendent là où se trouve le malade et est
sa famille où se trouvait le malade son
domicile et de sa famille et de ses
voisins à protéger l'euro à s'organiser
ils distribuent du savon des comprimés
de chlore et des fois même ils font ils
ont fait à la fin des petites unités de
fabrication d'eau potable et c'était
l'idée de diminuer la transmission
autour des cadres dans les jours qui
suivent le truc et ça ça a permis de
détourner petit à petit on a une courbe
qui est une jolie présentation de
stanislas rebrodé sur sur sa dont j'ai
mis le lien on a une courbe du choléra
orange foncé c'est pour au prince et les
environs le res d'haïti orange clair le
bleu c'est la pluie et cette ligne bleue
c'est le le nombre d' équipe de choléra
par rapport au nombre de cas de choléra
dans la journée et quand comme arrive à
fin 2016 et un peu plus d'argent donc le
nombre d'équipés et là il ya une sorte
de rupture d'équilibré entre le choléra
et la lutte plus de monde sur la lutte
moins de quatre choléra et on peut
concentrer les cas sur les foyers
résiduels et le choléra disparaît en
deux en deux ans complètement question
internet épidémie régional du collège
laeti duré neuf ans question combien de
temps estime-t-il que l'épidémie tco
vite durera d'ailleurs quels critères
permet d'affirmer qu'une épidémie toffee
cement et vos fils y helmand terminée
alors pour ce qui est du choléra va
falloir attendre trois ans mais à deux
ans et quelques parce que c'est un
critère presque administratif pour
l'épidémie de kovy dont on y reviendra
mais c'est celle dépend vraiment de
comment s'y prend voilà là dans cette
épidémie
de choléra pendant des années on n'a pas
fait ce qu'il fallait quand on a eu les
moyens de faire c'est tombé beaucoup
plus vite je termine simplement lassé la
situation donc
on a maintenant un recul de plus de deux
ans plus de deux mille prélèvements
c'est bien figuré par jour et il n'y a
plus un seul endroit où il ya du choléra
en haïti et les 2000 derniers
prélèvements sont tous négatifs
et ça n'empêche pas alors il ya première
chose la fondation bill et melinda gates
va envoyer une lettre fin 2018 on a
quelques semaines la fin du choléra mais
a surtout très très peu de cas est là et
il insiste pour pouvoir et 10 il vous
donne 10 millions de dollars à la global
tu as force vous dire merci
oui bien sûr merci pour organiser une
campagne de vaccination ils disent c'est
vraiment le moment de faire une campagne
de vaccination et c'est
malheureusement le choléra s'arrête un
peu vite je vous coupe encore question
internet en balançant le nom de bill et
melinda gates et de jpmorgan vous auriez
pas un peu envie de donner des arguments
aux complotistes
non je veux pas donner des arguments aux
complotistes ou alors ils viennent me
voir il leur explique les choses je
donne des faits je ne balance pas le nom
je les trouvais sur sur les documents
que la lettre c'est pas moi qui balance
le nom elle est là la lettre le dans
l'article de l'article financier il est
bien expliqué que c'est eux qui
possèdent le
l'entreprise gavi chacun sait on peut le
retrouver que la fondation gates est
partie prenante et le premier partenaire
privé dans gavi et c est ce que je
voudrais la foudre est à l'essai à ça
c'est à ça parce que mon mon problème
moi c'est l'intégrité scientifique en
quelque sorte est ce que je voudrais
c'est montrer maintenant cette
publication sur j'ai de bons gros c'est
un peu le contexte est derrière ce
contexte on voit arriver l'été dernier
une publication qui explique comment va
éliminer le choléra en haïti
avait pas de choléra depuis un an et
demi alors le optant qui soumettent le
truc il y avait déjà plus de choléra
depuis un an quand
et donc il cette cette publication par
deux modèles et va expliquer que comment
il faut faire donc voilà les méthodes et
vous voyez encore je balance je suis
désolé de balancer funding bill et
melinda gates à nouveau trois des quatre
équipes sont fondées sont financés par
la fondation gates la quatrième équipe
et fait son auto financement au niveau
de la suisse et donc c'est pas qu'ils
travaillent différemment c'est mais la
fondation gates avait besoin de ces
arguments et là on voit l'évolution du
choléra et on voit que dans le modèle
ben ça se passe un moment où il ya plus
de choléra bon
et là où ça ne va pas et donc on voit
que pour éliminer il faut avoir vacciné
en fait le résultat c'est vous
n'éliminerait pas si vous vacciner pas
la quasi totalité de la population etc
en même temps il ya de l'argent qui
attend pour des vaccins on a tout le
truc est quand même tout est prêt ils
sont prêts à commencer la campagne de
vaccination et finalement je vous je
termine sur une
sur une lettre réponse qui a été fait
par des collègues haïtiens le professeur
jean humenry ce qui est un ancien doyen
d'une dune des failles de médecine
d'haïti qui dirige une équipe de
recherche où ils travaillent sur le
choléra le docteur gerald leur bourque
et le président du comité d'éthique
d'haïti et d'autres qui vont répondre
quand même que 2 malgré et ils répondent
à cet article expliquant ils sont pas
contents parce que malgré le nikon de la
crise économique récente les problèmes
politiques
l'épidémie de covile le ministère de la
santé haïtien a toujours maintenu la
surveillance et produit des rapports sur
son site web il n'a trouvé aucun cluster
de cas suspects il n'y a eu aucun décès
par choléra depuis 2009 de 10,9 et des
cultures plus de maintenant près de 2000
que échantillons consécutifs sont
revenus négatifs
li et ses collègues devraient être au
courant de ça puisque une partie des
auteurs travaillent en haïti en
particulier sur la surveillance
microbiologique
donc nous considérons ces omission dans
l'article
l'omission de dire qu'il ya plus de cas
de choléra comme une des informations
cruciales et on est terminée sur les d
information
va passer sur notre petit bond pays sur
les petites statues qui symbolise le le
choléra la minustah en haïti à deux dos
et un haïtien qui firme en temps le
drapeau haïtien le pied sur casques
bleus de la minustah choléra c'est comme
ça qu'elle s'appelle c'est la réponse
d'haïti finalement toute cette histoire
puisque il faut un peu de dérision sinon
on arrive pas on embrasse sens super
bien ici maïs il va passer on va passer
sur les jeux relève la diapo oui bon on
a un réal qui peuvent appeler comme
aussi je peux poser sa wii attention pas
manipuler touche parce que ça contrôle
aussi notre juste valeur
par terre c'est très bien porter ses
très grands
mais voilà on va passer plus en détail
sur le co vide sur la stratégie
vaccinale
d'autres couvert de bon les importations
cas les visons des choses comme ça
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
stratégie du gouvernement macron avec
les vaccins les différents types de
vaccins
alors déjà la stratégie
globale
on pourrait considérer la qualifiée d'
être une stratégie de laisser la
transmission aux plus hauts qu'ils
soient supportables vivre qui l'épient
libye c'est plus que ça c'est celle et
c'est l'essai ne freinez que si c'est
absolument impossible de faire autrement
ils sont pensés en vacciner tout le
monde donc ça c'est fred a freiné du
style
mettre les gamins en vacances par
exemple du style fermer un certain
nombre de magasins distille le couvre
feu et tout ça ne de le faire a minima
et de tolérer une transmission élevé
jusqu'à ce que les vaccins soient
finalement renverse la tendance entre la
transmission de l'épidémie d'un côté les
vaccins de l'autre
ça c'est donc la stratégie vaccinale
finalement est le principal outil pour
faire les de réduire et comme les
vaccins arrivent que lentement
parce qu'il faut les produire parce que
si parce que ça on a cette situation
actuelle avec les hôpitaux surchargés et
le nombre de places en réa qu'on est
obligé d'augmenter semaine après semaine
qu'est ce qui se passe quand un pays ou
un continent est obligé de vivre avec
une une épidémie
il se passe que ce qui nous est arrivé
en europe c'est on a on a des pays qui
ont décidé de se battre vraiment pied à
pied dès le début
et qui
voit là ont réussi à maintenir le
pensent beaucoup des pays d'asie l'asie
n'est pas une île enfin bon aprés le il
ya aussi l'australie aussi la nouvelle
zélande mais il ya beaucoup de pays qui
qui ont fait un énorme effort pour ne
pas laisser rien que quelques cas c'est
parce qu'on a fait on a eu bien sûr la
première vague non au moment où ça a
diminué on aurait pu faire ça mais ça
pas été ce qu'on a fait et ensuite on a
eu en europe ce que ce qu'on a vécu
c'est un hiver terrible quoi ça avec
beaucoup de morts beaucoup de
restrictions parce que s'il ya beaucoup
de cas ont fini par quand même être
obligé de confiner de bloquer donc ce
que je souhaite c'est si on arrive à une
période à nouveau de très faibles
transmission qu'on se laisse pas avoir
en disant tiens on va laisser tous
repartir comme on veut
on peut ma condition d'avoir une
stratégie très solide de contact raguine
à côté et le courage d'arrêter
localement
quand c'est encore locale vous parlez de
stratégie
d'efficacité de cette stratégie
quand vous voyez en australie vous êtes
mis en quarantaine 14 jours à vos frais
pour 3000 dollars australiens qu'on
vient vous voir pour vous apporter à
manger devant votre porte vous allez
interdiction de sortir que de votre
transfert entre l'aéroport et l'hôtel
vous êtes suivis par la police que les
gens qui viennent vous tester tous les 5
jours viennent habillés en tenues de
cosmonaute que si vous voulez avoir des
comptes à terre extérieur c'est foutu
vous êtes vraiment coincé quinze jours
de confinement strict
quand on voyage horizons dans la
situation où ils sont ils ont raison
c'est pas la peine de se prendre une
vague épidémique vaut mieux embêter
quelques personnes pendant quinze jours
que se retrouvait avec une épidémie qui
n'arrive pas à contrôler et embêter la
totalité la population pendant des mois
durant alors quand on voit nous les
français
rappelez-vous l'épidémie de wayne - là
le départ one ont collé des petites
affichettes sanitaire qu'en maintenant
en 2021 vous arrivez d'afrique du sud du
brésil
vous avez juste un test pc à fournir qui
peut être soit faux soit trafiqué soit
une contrefaçon li déclaration sur
l'honneur que vous avez vous allez vous
isolez su pendant sept jours et puis hop
vous prenez le taxi et va rentrer à
paris
c'est pas magnifique qu'est ce que vous
en pensez ça c'est c'est de
l'incompétence c'est des branquignols
ils ont allégé ma réponse sur cet aspect
là un branquignol de compétences
montignac jury devait répondre sur le
fait que bon là actuellement il ya
beaucoup de cas c'est pas force déjà
c'est un problème même quand il ya
beaucoup de cas c'est un problème parce
que on laisse rentrer éventuellement de
nouveaux variants etc
mais au moment où le nombre de cas va
diminuer j'espère qu'on fera ce que font
les autres pays parce qu'actuellement
par exemple les anglais ou rentrée pas
comme ça vous êtes en quarantaine ont
entre 1 en angleterre d'après ce que
j'ai compris je peux aller vérifier mais
j'espère bien qu'au moment où ça va
baisser oui bon on fera pareil au moins
à partir de pays qui sont des pays jugés
dangereux parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
virus en circulation actuellement le
pays dangereux c'est nous c'est nous qui
ne pouvons plus aller en allemagne
au maroc mais je fonce je comprends très
bien les marocains ils ont raison
j'espère que fortis on est devenu un
pays du tiers monde nous c'est à dire
que on est en train de se faire refuser
l'accès à d'autres pays parce qu'on
n'est pas foutu d'avoir un protocole
strict pour endiguer l'épidémie sévit la
france c'est vraiment un des éléments de
la discussion que j'ai eue tout à
l'heure à l'elysée j'essaye de faire
passer cette idée que il faudrait pas
qu'on se retrouve je prends l'exemple
quand on va en afrique intertropicale
c'est quand même dangereux de point de
vue sanitaire faut faire attention le
paludisme me faire ne pas se faire
piquer par les moustiques donc amené des
petites avoir des moustiquaires
imprégnées ou enfin il ya tout un tas
précautions à prendre pour défendre
éventuel prophylaxie au moins donc on
hésite à y aller plein de gens hésitent
à y aller et puis surtout on retour on
fait on est tranquille là imaginons
c'est ce que j'ai essayé d'expliquer
imaginons un japonais qui veut venir en
europe puis la 60 70 ans il le faire du
tourisme 1 il va dans un pays qui de la
france si on fait pas ce qu'il faut il
va aller dans un pays qui va être jugé
dangereux pour lui il va il va pas y
aller et si par hasard il y va en retour
ces quinze jours de quarantaine chez lui
donc c'est un tulpan tue l'amour
ceinture tourisme ceinture tout à
l'heure actuellement l'australie est en
train de voir avec la nouvelle zélande
pour pouvoir faire des échanges la
nouvelle-zélande ou l'australie avait
que singapour rien certainement de
sécurité voilà une bulle de sécurité on
est complètement dehors on est dehors de
chez dehors j'espère que avec le lait
dans les mois qui viennent la situation
va s'améliorer avec l'immunité
partiel liée à la maladie le minitel
avec la vaccination il faudra qui est
quand même beaucoup de gens vaccinés et
pour son look si les enfants par les
enfants les aident le maximum en
tout ce qu'on peut vacciner doit être
vacciné si on veut y arriver
parce que mon idée il faut arriver à
zéro co vide et le ce qui manquera il
faut l'obtenir avec le contact tracking
et avec des actions ciblées aux endroits
du reste de la transmission est donc ça
veut dire qu'à ce moment là oui il
faudra faire une bulle et aider les
autres pays à se débarrasser si c'est si
on n'est pas les derniers parce que ça
pourrait nous arriver au point où on en
est donc c'est vraiment l'idée on s'est
raté
l'été dernier on avait une chance de
maintenir au niveau européen c'est pas
que la france au niveau européen on
avait une chance de maintenir les trucs
le fallait
effectivement verrouillé et c'est là
s'était ouverte où les gens pouvaient
venir les épidémies revenus de
l'extérieur et en os ou diddy que alors
la giz ça vient des bisous des singes
verts alors il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord il expliqué et ça on l'a vu nous
aussi que l'épidémie est partie en en
afrique c'est nous qui leur avons donné
en particulier mais pas que maghreb
aussi et ses revenus en juillet donc au
fait ça c'est un peu modifié explique ça
je crois qu'il a raison il a raison sur
ce le fait que l'épidémie passe d'un
côté puis repasse de l'autre et c'est
sur les visant
c'est vraiment quelque chose à regarder
de très près on manque de données mais
il le dit lui aussi au manque de données
si les visons d'élevage ou des contacts
icloud ou fouilles sauvages alors il
faut déjà comprendre que le vison semble
être très susceptibles au conte un virus
humain où l'homme encore le virus de
vision on a du mal à savoir qui est
l'oeuf et la poule dans cette histoire
là mais en tout cas manifestement au
partage avec le vison une susceptibilité
sur les coronavirus et c'est ce qui
s'est passé car induit lé
l'abattage de deux millions de visas
devises ont par exemple france et au
danemark si je me souviens bien et il ya
aussi peut-être des problèmes similaires
il ya des problèmes similaires mais on
n'a pas les souches on n'a pas les
séquences donc c'est difficile de savoir
didier rahout le dit d'ailleurs on n'a
pas les séquences donc sur ces points
lâchés d'accord avec didier rahout pas
sur la chloroquine mais sur ces pour la
wii
revenant sur les vaccins
est-ce que les vaccins nous protège
contre les variants
différemment selon les vaccins par
exemple astrazeneca
fonctionne mal sur le variant sud
africain
lui il ya eu un travail qui a été fait
et d'ailleurs les africains du sud ont
décidé de ne pas utiliser
cette astra zeneca ils ont réussi
d'ailleurs à revendre les doses à des
pays parce que il avait vraiment le
variant sud afrique mais si on prend le
finder le moderna il semble quand même
avoir une bonne efficacité sur ce
variant en tout cas sur le variant
onglet ça marche bien donc il n'ya pas
c'est pas une réponse homogène ça dépend
du vaccin ça dépend du variant
l'efficacité de toute façon par exemple
même du trailer est quand même moindre
sur le variant sud africain qu'elle ne
l'est sur le la souche classique ou même
le variant anglais
on va s'en sortir comme on va s'en
sortir a vécu des kills épidémie qui va
ruiner notre économie jusqu'à l'os on va
s'en sortir comme avec eux alors ouais
je le
si on continue mais finalement cette
histoire d'haïti était quand même
intéressante il s'est passé des années
avant qu'on fasse ce qui était vraiment
efficace mettre suffisamment des équipes
sur le terrain mais suffisamment de
personnes pour aider à casser la
transmission autour des malades c'est
pas la même manière c'est après mais
c'était vraiment ça et ça savez ça a
donné un super résultat mais il ya des
des obstacles très fort à faire ça
d'abord parce que d'un point de vue
économique ça ne rapporte rien de faire
ce genre de chose si ce n'est que ça
permet de lutter contre l'épidémie donc
faire comprendre ça deuxièmement c'est
compliqué à organiser c'est beaucoup de
logistique et troisièmement quand même
c'est les pays qui l'ont fait il ya des
pays qui l'ont fait et ça marche donc le
jour on se mettra ça dans la tête et on
développera vraiment sur le terrain ces
choses là on a des chances de s'en
sortir
c'est pas ça ils s'agitent pour rien
c'est ça non c'est pas con s'agit de
poursuivre rire mais c'est par exemple
et ça maintenant là on l'a bien mesurer
si on disait simplement que le vaccin ça
nous a aidé le vaccin n'est que le
vaccin alors on ne peut pas lever les
gestes barrières parce que d'abord il ya
des gens qui vont pas se vacciner il
faudrait qu'on ait le minimum et
deuxièmement le vaccin est pas 100%
efficace on l'a vu sur les vars et la
transmission
oui la transmission eux mêmes la
protection quand on dit 95% de
protection pour l'astra zen et pour le
finder ou le modern a qui sont les plus
c'est très bien mais ça veut dire qu'il
ya quand même 5 % donc
je là ça fait il faut après multiplier
le nombre de personnes vaccinées par
l'efficacité etc et on a le nombre de
personnes protégées fonctionnement de
penser à vous protéger si on avait que
le vaccin ce qu'il atteigne 80 % avec la
contagiosité actuel de la souche ça
c'est compliqué quand même donc on va
devoir faire de toute façon quelque
chose en plus des pays se sont
débrouillés sans le vaccin pour
maîtriser l'épidémie et qu'on arrête de
dire ce sont des îles le vietnam n'est
pas une île la chine n'est pas une île
un cambodge est pas une île et il y en a
plein des pays comme ça là les pays
d'asie centrale y en a pas mal qui sont
qui se sont bien sortis c'est pas tout
ça mais donc il ya plein de pays comme
ça mais nous on a considéré que c'était
pas pour nous ça ce genre de choses
alors on n'a pas besoin de flics et
forcément on a besoin d'accompagner qui
est du monde le monde peut être des gens
pour vous aider ou des gens pour mettre
des pv et là c'est peut-être plus
efficaces d'aidé que de mettre des pv en
réalité convient aux vaccins
forcer votre vaccin vous de 12 ça vous
évite une forme grave et ça empêche
aussi la transmission ça diminue le
risque de transmission et ça ça a été
mesurée cdc des études plus récentes non
il est beaucoup moins de porter
pourtant oui alors je me souviens plus
des chiffres mais c'est quand même très
grande majorité enfin je parle là de des
vaccins qui ont été le plus étudié en
tout cas il ya une publication dans le
new england journal of medecine sur le
kaiser ou father et de modern à je ne
sais plus mais qui montre que finalement
il ya une très bonne efficacité sur la
transmission sur le fait d'être porteur
donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant on s'en
doutait quand on voit les l'évolution de
l'épidémie en israël où au royaume uni
on comprend bien qu'il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé avec le vaccin on a
d'ailleurs nous quelque chose de très
intéressant à l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris on avait une
courbe des cases chez le personnel qui
se superposent et à l'incidence de du
coronavirus en région parisienne et
depuis quelques semaines les courbes se
sont dissociés l'incidence était en
train de rome remonter fortement pour
dans la population générale et ce dans
le personnel de l'ap-hp c'est en train
de ça s'est stabilisé de voir ça descend
qu'est-ce qui se passe le nombre de
personnes descendent c'est en ça s'est
stabilisé voire ça descend c'est à dire
sur les derniers jours peut-être on peut
penser que ce à dessein c'est pour ça
que je vais pas plus loin un jardin on
va voir mais le différentiel entre les
deux est vraiment spectaculaire et ça on
le rattache au fait qu' on a passé la
barre des 50 %
de personnels de l'ap-hp qui a au moins
vacciner sur une dose et beaucoup sur
deux doses puisque les deux doses à
trois semaines d'intervalle et donc on a
des éléments très encourageant alors
petit point en chantant toujours dire
que les gens dans les hôpitaux seront
pas vaccinés patin couffin le jour où il
y aura des vaccins qui seront pas
utilisées ok les vaccins tous les
faiseurs etc pour l'instant vous mettez
1020ef la kaiser ils partent aussitôt
donc on est à 50 % je pense qu'on va
monter beaucoup plus beaucoup plus haut
j'espère qu'on montre beaucoup plus haut
mais en tout cas on peut pas dire que
les gens veulent pas se faire vacciner
quand on leur a pas proposé un vaccin
l'astra zi qar
on dit que ça fait d'être au bout ce que
ça peut créer des morts est-ce que vous
pouvez rassurer les gens par rapport à
cela alors que certains pays
rôtir l'astra zenica de langue leur
propre marché
lâche et simplement alors maintenant
l'astra zeneca est proposé aux personnes
au dessus de 55 ans alors ça rassure ça
rassure par
le bénéfice le risque de mourir de l'aco
vide pour une personne de plus de 50 55
ans est beaucoup plus important que le
risque de ces thrombose qui d'ailleurs
sont plutôt pour des personnes un peu
plus jeune mais en tout cas le rapport
bénéfices risques est très favorable aux
vaccins sur les personnes de plus de 55
ans pour les personnes de moins de 55
ans je pense que ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'on va leur proposer en deuxième
dose c'est le truc de l'achat des
dans la chaise se dire des saloperies de
spécialisation à domicile la lola haute
autorité de santé
à proposer là il ya 24 heures j'ai pas
le temps de regarder en détail mais si
j'ai bien compris les gens comme une
première dose d'astrazeneca seront dès
qu'il y avait moins de 50 50 donc c'est
du personnel soignant essentiellement
seront vaccinés en deuxième dose par un
vaccin est reine
le fait que ça met du temps qu'on
vaccine
l'intégralité de notre population est ce
que ça représente des risques parce
qu'il a aidé du
tout ce temps qui passe ces débats en
plus c'est des morts en plus c'est
l'écho vie de l'ong plus c'est des
troubles neurologiques en plus c'est
des du personnel en burn out en plus
c'est des hôpitaux c'est des patients
pour d'autres maladies qui
se retrouve en pas diagnostiquées ou des
greffes de rein qui sont retardés des
choses comme ça oui bien sûr plus vite
on sort de ça mieux c'est hélas se
posait la question de d'agir peut-être
un peu plus en amont ça n'a pas été la
solution choisie mais c'était vraiment
celle que moi j'aurais souhaité vous
parlez de troubles neurologiques ou est
atteinte sur le cerveau
il ya eu récemment une étude qui dit qu'
un tiers des patients hospitalisés j'ai
vu ça j'ai pas le temps de regarder en
détail ressortent avec des troubles
neurologiques voire psychiatrique c'est
ça c'est de ça dont je voulais parler
mais j'ai pas le temps de le regarder en
détail à chaque fois revoir voir une pub
lille en sort plein voir une pub livre
passé une heure dessus donc
je vais le faire mais si j'avais le même
topo à préparer quand on voit en
belgique dont le parc lacombre qui est
un partisan magnifique
la police belge chargé avec la police
les canons à eau et leurs méthodes
archaïques d'envoyer la cavalerie sur
des gamins est en train de faire la
fiesta est ce que c'est parce qu l'état
belge commune d'ailleurs l'état français
anticipent des conséquences à long terme
sur la santé publique et donc sur son
économie
et on voit la méthode forte sans dire
voilà vous êtes en train de vous 30 à
midi ça représente des points de pib en
bois dans cinq 5 ou 10 ans
est-ce que vous pensez que les états se
tendent parce qu'ils sont en train de
comprendre que les copies de long les
maladies
neurologiques ou cardiaques ou
hépatiques vont représenter des points
de pib en moins sur l'échiquier
géoéconomique
ça a pas l'air de marché en france alors
je sais pas trop bien sûr je vais pas
répondre sur ce que fait l'état belge et
par rapport aux manifestations la
manière de les gérer c'est pas moi de
répondre sur ces histoires là ça ça
suffit déjà de d'avoir des critiques
extrêmement précises sur les choses que
je connais bien je veux pas me mettre à
critiquer des choses que je connais pas
bien ça ne paraît pas être des choses à
faire mais c'est vraiment pas mon
domaine mais par contre la réponse sur
prise de conscience de ces qu'ovide long
ces troubles j'imagine aussi il y avait
l'histoire des écoles et des collèges et
des lycées
ils ont attaqué en france un parent
collective et imaginons un collégien qui
a
été montré dans les études comme corps
de l'institut pasteur qu' une partie
importante de l'arrivée du virus dans
les familles venaient mais finalement
parle maintenant par des enfants avec le
les enfants les adolescents et on disait
qu'ils se débattent en règle et c'est le
virus a changé quand même c'était peut
porter là ils le sont beaucoup plus pas
plus que les adultes mais pratiquement
autant pour les adolescents et moi je me
dis qu'elle peut être la charge de ces
enfants qui ont pu amener le virus
la charge psychologique d'amener le
virus dans la famille si ça se passait
mal pour un membre de la famille et donc
je mettrai ça en face aussi de de ce
qu'on nous a dit des problèmes de
scolarité les problèmes de deux
dépressions sachant que globalement la
pandémie entraîne vraiment des problèmes
à tout le monde et psychiatriques et
psychologiques à tout le monde
j'aurais évité quand même de mettre tout
d'un côté en dix ans les son vivant avec
le virus et finalement les gens se
porteront mieux psychologiquement je
suis pas sûr et bon c'est pas l'option
qu'ont été cas été prises maintenant on
aujourd'hui à ce niveau là le pic va
bientôt arriver où il est peut-être déjà
arrivé en région parisienne on sait pas
puis des nouvelles contaminations pic
derrière de toute façon c'est un peu
plus tard ça va redescendre mais ça va
redescendre c'est à peu près convaincu
c'est à ce moment là qu'est ce qu'on
fait on laisse les choses cool et comme
ça et puis ça restera un niveau de base
ou est ce que on pousse pour que cette
redescente soit la dernière celle qui
permet de prendre le contrôle de la
maladie comme le font presque la moitié
des pays au monde
est ce que est ce que vous avez étudié
les facteurs météo dans la propagation
du virus et surtout d'humilité
oui alors il ya eu des études nous nous
mêmes avec léon j'ai parlé dans le
coller dans le choléra d' jean godard de
stanislas remodèle on travaille aussi
ensemble on a regardé un peu aussi ce
genre de choses et puis on l'a vu aussi
à l'automne quand il a commencé à faire
froid dans certains départements et pas
dans d'autres on avait un différentiel
donc il ya des des travaux qui montrent
que quand on est entre
autour de 10 degrés 5 10 degrés là il ya
quand même des conditions plus propices
terme d'aero contamination une chose
comme ça donc on peut espérer si c'est
ça la question sous jacente on peut
espérer que le mois de mai nous apporte
un peu d'air et les fusées lit une
accalmie d'autant plus qu'on va pouvoir
ouvrir les fenêtres et ça aussi on sait
que l'atmosphère confinée et est
embêtante donc il a il fait bien chaud
vous n'avez fait vacciner j'ai des
anticorps au top et tout ça dont je vous
transmettrai rien donc quand on voit le
texas fanfaronner parce qu'ils ont levé
les restrictions ils ont plus de masques
et que j'irai le michigan de mémoire
c'est à dire
ils région beaucoup plus aux doors voix
voix sont des piliers augmenté alors
qu'ils ont un confinement à tout ça le
facteur bt où il jouerait beaucoup
peut-être d'autres causes mais ça joue
sajou ou sajoo mais attention on a eu
quand même aux états unis si on parle du
texas et de la floride pendant l'été
parce que d'ailleurs nous aussi un
marseille au mois d'août était un des
endroits où il y avait le plus de
transmissions
c - doute marseille est plus que mais
parce que alors le
la chaleur pour normalement devrait
éviter donc on peut avoir
la météo joue mais pas au point
d'empêcher la transmission la pollution
joue aussi je sais pas
quand que vous voyez des dix clandestins
fête fête fête fait par la route ouais
d'ailleurs on va se faire un truc là
après non c'est ça ou ça se parle on va
chez carreau voilà vous vivienne
ils font des dîners clandestins ou
d'autres on est des carnavals wii ou
d'aider des policiers qui transforme des
barbecues ou clusters qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que vous pensez de salles
l'exemplarité nous forces de l'ordre il
a la mauvaise tenue de route gérer ce
qui sont ici sans le facteur à risque
les dîners les dînettes lundi d'abord au
effectivement dans la hotte ça se
transmet bien parce qu'on a encore eu
quand même un certain nombre de deux
personnes de personnalités touché ces
derniers temps donc effectivement alors
ça peut être professionnel on peut
l'imaginer mais de toute façon dont
s'est pas défendable ces dîners
clandestins en même temps
on a du mal même dans les hôpitaux
à
faire que pendant tout le temps toute
l'année et c'est on se contaminent pas
on sait que et des contaminations
pendant les repas à ces professionnels
oui oui ben c'est quand on vous envoie
ou au turbin première ligue ok oui mais
ont normalement il faudrait pas qu'on
mange à plus de temps d'antenne trucks
ans d'ouvrir les portes ne mâchait tout
ça alors là on essaie de le faire enfin
quand on peut on essaye de le faire
quand vous voulez mais je veux dire
c'est pas si facile alors ce n'est pas
une excuse mais c'est en fait il faisait
la différence entre les dîners
clandestins effectivement si ça existe
et c'est etc
ben faut leur taper sur les doigts n'y a
pas de doute le barbecue que ce soit des
policiers que ce soit dès qu'ils sont
censés faire maintenir les ouïes
restrictions sanitaires ils ont un
devoir d'exemplarité
ouais mais après
cdc police
doit reconnaître alors je veux bien je
veux bien dire j'ai pas fait de barbecue
au de trucs comme ça ça m'est arrivé
quand même de passer une soirée en
dehors de chez moi vous étiez pas 80 non
non 4 par exemple ça marche quand vous
voyez
le documentaire de france 3 france
télévisions de plus de 50 minutes sur
les origines du virus
j'ai pas vu vous n'avez pas vu un nord
alors où quand même il pointe fortement
la direction
d'un virus avec gain de fonction
qui aurait été fait dans la région new
one dans dans le fameux laboratoire p3
et p4
c'est crédible c'est pas crédible quand
les chinois refusent de donner une
souche qu'ils auraient récolté dans une
mine ou 6 des dans le yunnan tout à fait
là où il ya plein de chausse oui oui ils
refilent la souche quand les chinois ils
fassent leurs bases de données ne la
rendre plus accessible
c'est quoi ça est-ce que c'est est ce
qu'on pourrait lire sans faire trop de
supputations une stratégie de bon ton
calme les choses
c'est pas nous pas vu pas pris
quand j'ai présenté l'histoire du panel
vous avez vu que
ça pouvait avoir certaine résonance dans
ce qu'on peut voir
le problème c'est que il n'ya pas plus
de dents quête au au coeur du système
qui sortent une information dès lors que
l'information n'est pas sorti on peut
pas dire qui c'est passé une fuite de
laboratoire que ce soit un virus
améliorée c'est une hypothèse ça reste
une hypothèse malheureusement quand on
efface un certain nombre de choses des
bases de données par les d'effacer les
preuves pour haïti quand on efface une
base de données quand on ne rend plus
accessible certaines informations
effectivement pourrait toujours se poser
la question de pourquoi c'est effacé
qu'est ce qui ce qui posait problème
mais en tout cas on sera toujours devant
des questions
je peux pas il aurait fallu que
quelqu'un soit appelée par je sais pas
trop qui pour enquêter et le fasse
et le courage de sortir les informations
mais immédiatement c'est un an après
c'est compliqué donc à la fois se trouve
pas ça normal que les données soient
cachés mais une fois qu'elles sont
cachés je peux pas les inventer c'est
une enquête de l'oms qui s'est déplacé
sur place et ses cookies vie c'est quoi
je n'ai pas fait le travail que j'ai
fait sur l' enquête de l'onu
j'ai moins d'informations sur cette
enquête de l'om est-ce faut du temps
pour le faire j'encourage tous ceux qui
veulent regarder ça en détail à le
regarder à communiquer leur leurs
résultats mais
j'avoue que je serais même pas dire le
nom des personnes qui ont fait l'anc est
ce qu elle a eu lieu c'est qu'elle a
conclu que c'est hautement improbable et
c'est bien là le
claire-lise chaignat qui disait qu'il
était un traitement improbable que le
ville que le choléra a été apportée par
un humanitaire donc le c'est pas
forcément convaincant ce
en même temps
j'ai aucune preuve et personne n'a
aucune preuve que ça vienne d'un
laboratoire on peut juste s'inquiéter
sur les difficultés à obtenir ces
informations
question internet comment contrôler
l'épidémie quand le gouvernement fait
bourde sur bourde qui donne du grain à
moudre aux théories alternatives entre
guillemets et que les français désertent
leur lieu de résidence dès que l'on met
un confinement locale
oui en plus finalement c'est fait avec
une certaine tolérance c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
oui il ya eu des bourdes et comment se
comporter c'est là le sens de ce que
j'essaye de faire en tout cas c'est pour
résumer
j'essaye bon maintenant il ya vraiment
ils ont plus vraiment besoin de beaucoup
d'informations supplémentaires au niveau
de la direction de l'ap-hp
ils sont très bien informés
mais au niveau des par exemple il ya une
députée qui me demande régulièrement
pose des questions par écrit je réponds
je réponds quel que soit le rêve je
réponde de manière factuelle comme j'ai
essayé de le faire et en espérant qu'une
partie de l'information arrive à ces
questionnaires sont aussi envoyé au
ministre de la santé aux premiers
ministres à l'elysée et j'ai pu vérifier
qu'effectivement les questionnaires
étaient bien adressé enfin arrivé bien à
la conseillère santé du président de la
république après il faut j'essaie de
leur donner des infos les collègues
d'autres collègues j'ai pas tout seul
les modélisateurs donne des infos arnaud
fontanet fait d'excellents enquête qui
permettent d'avoir des de savoir d'où
viennent les contaminations etc on fait
ce qu'on peut pour les éclairer et je
pense que quand même un ensemble de
scientifiques qui font le job avec ça on
en a d'autres d'abord on était quand
même quelques guignols qui se pavanent
devant les dans les télés qui disent un
peu n'importe quoi et puis on a eu quand
même des des choses plus embêtante plus
complotistes etc qui n'arrange pas non
plus le le discours c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué mais en tout cas on
essaye nous d'informer après ça nous
jusqu'ici ça n'a pas empêché ce que vous
appelez des bourdes en tout cas des
options des options stratégiques in ce
marché
voilà je sais pas par exemple on peut
parler des dépistages massive dans les
villes
pour savait que ça n'allait pas marcher
j'ai essayé de l'expliquer mais alors
comme les dépistages dans les lycées
tant qu'on n'est pas dans un nid à un
niveau il ya très peu de cas dans ce cas
là il ya quelques cas dans un lycée on y
va enfin dépistage complet mais prendra
lycée aujourd'hui un autre lycée mais
non ça ne peut pas marcher compact vous
prenez le cas des lycées des écoles
l'aller les dernières mesures c'est bon
un cas ça va de kassav ou 3 kg tout le
monde et contacts mais ils ont ils ont
l'air d'été avant une marge de tolérance
relativement importante dans les écoles
c'est quoi c'est pour pallier fermi
c'est pour vous pour actuellement de
façon il ya trop de cas c'est le far
west et à trop de casse et en plus
c'est mon avis est qu'il aurait fallu et
je n'étais pas le seul à le dire fermer
les écoles en février consensus on se
l'était dit 29 janvier donc je le répète
on aurait une situation beaucoup plus
confortable maintenant même si on les
avait ouvert au début du mois de mars
parce qu'on partait de plus bas se monte
à la même vitesse mais en partant de
plus bas on serait moins ou donc ça le
reste et devient derrière comment on
fait on n'a pas les moyen de dépister
chaque écolier chaque collégien chaque
lycéen deux fois par semaine c'est près
ce qu'il faudrait faire
si on voulait travailler comme ça mais
c'est juste pas possible par contre
quand ça va baisser les lycées les
collèges dont vont être ouverts etc s'il
ya un cas plus ce sera bas quand tu
auras un cas quelque part il faut
dépister tout le monde et tout bon c'est
dans la famille la grand-mère les
voisins les pis si tous les doutes déjà
tous les lycéens tous leurs trucs et
puis ensuite effectivement dans la
classe aller chercher à fabriquer sur
dix lycéens il a pris bus avec son
masque ni un peu n'importe comment il a
toussé dans le bus il faut tracer tous
bus si on trouve retrouve les gens qui
sont non vues ça c'est plus compliqué
que ça leur entrée
et des choses qui sont faisable d'autres
qui ne le sont pas si on faisait déjà
des choses faisable mais à un moment où
s'ébat à ce moment là on maîtrisera la
situation s'est pas on cherche pas à
être à 100% efficace on cherche à faire
en sorte que un cas non compagne en
contamine moins d'en moyenne si on
arrive à maintenir toujours cette
condition en permanence alors le
l'épidémie va sur la descente et ne
remontent pas
et donc on peut avoir des échecs on peut
avoir des des cas qu'on n'aura pas
repéré etc mais font repérer
suffisamment et intervenir suffisamment
autour de chacun de ces cas
commis sur internet en ce moment sur les
vaccins à arn il ya beaucoup de perche
et qui raconte que ça favorise les
cancers sa stérilise les gens qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez répondre à ces gens là
pour les rassurer
on n'a rien trouvé de ce type là dans
ces vaccins arn
telle première fac signer
j'ai pas d'inquiétude sur ce sur ce truc
là je suis prêt à le dire quand il ya un
problème supra le dire mais là on en a
pas vu donc
on va voir ce qui se passe mais
franchement rien ne se passe
actuellement
de ce côté là par rapport à ma part les
deux des thromboses maintenant on semble
me semble qu'ils aient des problèmes
avec les thromboses simplement et un
rapport bénéfice risque pour le vaccin
arn le cancer pour l'instant on n'a rien
n'établit on n'a aucune raison comprends
pas comment ça fonctionne ray et c'est
ce qui se passe les n'a aucune raison de
le penser
et faut pas s'inquiéter sur des trucs
qu'on a sur lequel on a pas de raison
question internet le brésil et il lit
poudrière invariants pour le monde pas
seulement le brésil qui doute la france
oui
enfin pourquoi parce qu elle
suffisamment de virus en circulation
mais des variants on en voit l'autre
jour dernières informations ils ont fait
sur mont d'or ils ont fait mille
séquence c'est la semaine dernière je
crois
ils ont trouvé des nouveaux variants ne
savent pas ce que c'est mais on trouvera
ils en trouvent tout le temps quand vous
parlez de tracking oui
ça pose des problèmes en termes de vie
privée ça terme ça pose des problèmes en
temps de de
vos déplacements
alors ça dépend comment comment s'y
prend
si le tracking alors de toute façon dont
vous avez un test vous allez être
appelée
suis pas dramatique quand même il ya
quand même un certain nombre de
précautions mais ensuite s'il s'agit
d'une discussion pour moi le tracking ne
doit pas être fait indépendamment de la
compagnon ça c'est quelque chose que je
défends c'est à dire on peut parce que
finalement ce qu'on a fait en haïti spy
1 et un problème de vie privée des
équipes vont là où il ya des cas de
choléra et puis
distribuer de l'eau du savon de quoi se
protéger contre le choléra oui un
problème de vie privée mais c'est pour
protéger les gens autour
là il s'agit d'appeler les personnes et
de discuter avec elle de qu'elle est la
meilleure manière de la coupe de les
accompagner etc et ensuite de voir avec
elle qui sont les contacts à la limite
une personne qui refuserait donné ses
contacts seuils de la convaincre puis on
est on peut aussi lui passer le message
et je défends sont aussi disant ben vous
voulez pas les donner alors appelez vous
même mais voilà ce qu'il faut leur dire
voilà alors ce qui est important il ya
un numéro de téléphone 0 800 130 et puis
plein de zéros après donc voilà où ils
peuvent appeler etc mais
ça par rapport à la vie privée enfin je
trouve que la vie privée c'est gentil
mais la mienne elle est pourrie en ce
moment depuis un an
par rapport à des à des problèmes de
fin de la liberté beaucoup moins
atteintes parce que quelqu'un m'appelle
au téléphone si j'ai été positif que
parce que quand je veux sortir j'ai une
amende
alors vous vous dites qu'il faut
vacciner beaucoup de personnes
mary france en france qu'il faudra
vacciner tout le monde en france d'une
il ya des personnes fantômes des
personnes sans papiers des personnes qui
sombre et caché des personnes qui n'ont
aucune existence légale comment on va
faire avec là c'est pareil entre une
aiguille et enfin aussi si on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer
vacciner des personnes sans prendre leur
nom
si si c'est ça le problème on peut tout
à fait imaginer ne sait pas qui en ce
moment parce que qu'est-ce qu'une envie
recommencer à se marchent il faut il
faut s'inscrire et c'est donc je sais
pas si s'il est demandé que les
personnes et un numéro de sécu ou un
truc comme ça je pense qu'il faut
prévoir comme aussi à des personnes
âgées qui voyagent difficilement qui se
déplace difficilement des équipes qui
peuvent aller les collègues de médecins
généralistes paris ont proposé de faire
des équipes d'ailleurs pour aller
vacciner comme ça éventuellement à
domicile on peut tout à fait imaginer
des vaccinations fait pour des personnes
sans qu'on leur demande leur nom vous
allez on y verra des femmes ici mais
vous allez à coucher et vous voulez pas
donner votre nom vous accouché sous x
donc c'est quelque chose qui existe on
peut qu'on pourrait se faire vacciner
sous x en quelque sorte il faut suggérer
ça aussi au gouvernement il sera obligé
d'en passer par là
faudra le faire oui oui si vous filmez
là si on ne fait pas ça on laisse une
partie de la population on augmente le
nombre de personnes sceptiques de
d'offrir un chemin au virus question
internet
la diversité des variants du coc vide
n'empêche telle pas purement et
simplement l'efficacité globale de tuv
axe
je le répète le vaccin nous fait faire
une partie du chemin mais si on ne met
pas à côté une stratégie de
d'accompagnement de contact rakeen on
n'aura pas fait suffisamment de chemin
on n'arrivera pas à ça deuxièmement on
peut imaginer que alors il ya des choses
qui se passent dire que les limitations
des digues dans des branches différentes
du virus les mutations convergent parce
qu'en fait ça permet au virus de mieux
s'adapter à sa cible
le virus c'est un peu comme une
je peux continuer
le virus c'est un peu comme une clé qui
va rentrer dans une serrure 1 c'est
vraiment il ya une adaptation cette
adaptation est extrêmement précise et
finalement les
les différents virus sont en train de
converger sur ce point là ça veut dire
que on peut imaginer que des vaccins
suivant des injections suivante vise ces
lieux de convergence et donc rendre le
vaccin plus efficace sur les variants là
c'est un commentaire internet dans la
zone question d aller faire tirer les
oreilles je vais vous lire son
commentaire et j'aimerais que vous lui a
répondu
entre guillemets vous avez 10 et des
morts en plus et son commentaire ces
audits mans quand on sait que 99 6%
survivent on sait que c'est pas un peu
trop quand même alors c'est pas 99 6%
quand même finalement les le plus près
de quatre ans de 99% et puis ça dépend
de l'âge
le problème qui se pose c'est d'abord il
y a
des familles aucune mort né et
acceptables enfin bon on est tous là
pour mourir mais si on peut faire vivre
notre vie correctement c'est mieux et
le problème qui se pose ce qu'elle est
mort il est malade et les entrées en
réanimation vous avez nous ça nous
arrive comme ça les malades la rive il
n'arrive plus à respirer et cherche
l'air il cherche qu'est ce qu'on fait on
va dire bon nombre vous êtes passé
nombreux on s'occupe pas de vous non on
va prendre en charge mais on a besoin de
place en réanimation s'il sait la
situation s'aggrave on sait qu'on peut
sauver des gens et
donc de toutes façons
les malades viennent sur l'hôpital et
les il faut s'en occuper on peut pas
dire bonne façon c'est pas grave on
laissait les qui se débrouille il faut
s'en occuper il y a vous avez des
médecins des soignants ils ont en face
des personnes qui sont en train de
chercher à respirer chercher l'air et on
ce qui est intolérable c'est de ne plus
avoir de quoi s'en occuper
quand une épidémie évolue trop fort au
même moment trop de personnes qui
arrivent n'a pas de quoi s'en occuper ça
détruit bien sûr c'est des gens qui
meurent mais c'est aussi du personnel
soignant qui est détruit et puis si on
est dans une période de
submersion des hôpitaux on n'est plus à
un pour cent on a deux ou trois ou
quatre pour cent de mort
alors est ce que finalement peu ce
départ se débrouiller et se dire bon 24
% de morts les hôpitaux le personnel
complètement détruit et ses c'est pas
grave qu'est ce qu'il met en face notre
auditeur qu'est-ce que vous quel est le
la chose si importante qu'il met en face
pour que quelques pour cent de la
population
enfin pour dire que c'est pas grave que
quelques pour cent de la population
meurt dans ces conditions-là
site internet pourquoi l'europe utilise
le vaccin chinois ils sont pourtant à la
pointe en matière de co vide et leur
vaccin est probablement celui qui était
le plus largement testé
par la simple vaccination massive de la
population chinoise alors là je rajoute
le vaccin rue soucy et à plaisir alors
pour le chinois d'abord il ya plusieurs
vaccins chinois mais ce que j'ai vu
c'est au chili
où il est il en ce moment landry c'est
ça ils ont ils utilisent un des vaccins
des vaccins chinois et comme il manque
d'efficacité dans toutes les villes tous
les vaccins se veut se valent pas alors
je peux pas savoir sur les trois vaccins
chinois mais là sur l'exemple du chili
sont beaucoup vacciner mais il ya quand
même une remontée du nombre de cas donc
je suis allé regarder ça effectivement
donc moi je n'aurais pas tendance quand
même a lieu en tout cas celui là de
l'utiliser les deux autres se croit
qu'il ya trois vaccins chinois mais
c'est pas parce qu'un vaccin qu'il est
qu'il est maire les autres alors le le
spoutnik vais probablement
est un bon vaccin mais on aimerait bien
avoir des données précises on les a pas
encore le jour où on les a je trouverais
si ces données sont effectivement
encourageantes
ben oui pourquoi on s'interdirait alors
là je sais pas ce qui se passe pourquoi
ya pas les donner à ce que c'est les
risques les produisons pas procuré est
ce que on tarde à les regarder ça n'en
sais rien
est ce que vous voyez quelque chose avec
nous il ya des centaines de questions
qui arrive qui arrive qui arrivera pas
pouvoir tout les prendre je suis prêt à
vous apprendre encore que les
techniciens sont fatigués
et parce qu'il travaille fort d'ailleurs
merci la ligue 1
est ce que vous voyez quelque chose à
rajouter qu'on n'a pas traité ce qui est
un point important qu'on n'a pas soulevé
je sais pas moi aussi je peux la journée
celle des petits fours à l'elysée j'ai
eu droit j'ai droit vers un verre d'eau
c'est déjà bien vous avez été de l'avion
non mais de trois questions quand même
et puis on arrête et comment le vaccin
ce music s'articule avec le passeport
vaccinale
les gens qui sont sans papiers sont sans
passeport ces bleus il le virus ne le
verra pas donc d'un côté le vaccin sous
x là on peut toujours enfin où c'est
difficile de faire un passeport sans
mettre le nom dessus
quant au passeport vaccinale de toute
façon j'ai peur que ce soit quelque
chose qui deviennent un peu une habitude
entre les pays et ses comptes quand je
voyage je dois produire un passeport
pour alliés en afrique je dois produire
une preuve de vaccination contre la
fièvre jaune ça ne pose pas tant de
problèmes que ça probablement ce sera
nécessaire connaît-il les vaccins cubain
non je ne sais pas
j'ai vu que
j'ai pas le temps de lire l'article j'ai
vu l'article qui est sorti et j'ai pas
le temps de le regarder
est-ce que vous avez des livres à
concilier notre commun
alors maintien pour
la peste de camus comme très très bonne
description delà de ce commence par une
épidémie
pour ce qui est du choléra le hussard
sur le toit
et puis ceux qui lisent l'anglais le
livre de ralph freaks en français vous
en avez fait en effet un mets sur le sur
le choléra sur l'histoire d'haïti c'est
quand même intéressant de lire
cette histoire si
elle existe elle est écrite et ça vaut
le coup de regarder mais camus la peste
et jaune all stars sur le toit c'est 7,2
bon bouquin que j'aime beaucoup dernière
question internet bonsoir
quelle confiance accorder ou rapports et
enquêtes des organisations
internationales l'exemple d'haïti nous
montrent qu'elles sont largement
faillible je suis d'accord on fait pour
un remettre la confiance dans le milieu
scientifique
va falloir faire le ménage je pense mais
cynthia ne sais pas je suis pas je vais
pas un partisan des des kalachnikovs
bazooka et les choses comme ça c'est pas
dans mon dans mon adn on va dire des
plus plus de l'huile de vidange sur le
sur les nerfs
non je pense que l'apple sûr c'est
toujours sur ses rapports mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas trés pas très simple
mais
regardez source et enfin tous les trucs
habituels et
avoir dans la tête que c'est pas parce
que le logo de telles organisations etc
y compris des organisations humanitaires
et pas que les fondations etc parce qu'à
ça que c'est forcément bon que c'est
forcément objectif est de bonne qualité
donc après fo ouais c'est compliqué mais
il faut se font garder une distance par
rapport à tous ces trucs là est-ce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
tout sur pareille être patient quand on
voit ce qui se passe c'est que ça enfin
je dis est faux faut être un peu zen
parce que sinon on n'y arrivera pas un
professeur renaud piarroux merci merci
[Musique]